okay so uh for those of you that have
been wondering whether this is an april
fool's joke or not it is not we actually
have [ __ ]
yogurt in the house today so we're not
playing a joke on people no not yet no
maybe throughout the next two hours
there'll be some surprises yeah but look
i'm i'm a guy that's been in a
what do you call it a prankster family
my entire life my family from both sides
are pranksters but this morning you
rarely are able to get me on april fools
i'm on my way here focused on what i'm
doing i'm driving the car
mario sends me a text message i got to
tell mario this folks i'm begging you to
get mario prank mario i'm sending
everybody to prank mario mario
yeah he runs the show after he says just
an fyi that the team is still trying to
repair the water damage that happened
last night to the new switcher keyboard
it's not looking good but we should
start on time uh with the old sling
which always gives us issues
we just sent somebody over to best buy
to get another one so i call mario mario
what are you talking about it's gonna
cost about eight thousand dollars i said
who did this he said i think george you
know spilled some coffee or something on
the switch i'm losing my mind he says i
gotta go they're having a meeting and
i'm like i call him back he says but
we're gonna be okay april fool's i'm
like you gotta be kidding me so mario
got me today i gotta give him credit
anyways it's good to have you on today
man really thanks for coming out good to
be here yeah i i i've obviously followed
your stuff for many years you can't
nowadays with what you've done over the
last decade or two decades um for people
that don't know you you i think one of
your channels got
uh six plus billion views online five
million subscribers i think total you
guys got 13 million plus subscribers
uh 10 12 billion plus views uh from
msnbc to coming and doing what you're
doing with young turks
a lot of i think a lot of people have a
love and hate relationship with you
we're going to talk a lot about today
which you know we're not going to spend
a lot of time talking sports that was
offline we're gonna talk some politics
but for some people that don't know
maybe give your journey of how you went
from there to young turks yeah sure um
so we started young turks about 20 years
ago at the time it was
the first original talk show on sirius
satellite radio
and then i always wanted to go online
video and so
we had an interesting journey through a
lot of different radio first including
air america xm etc but then we went
online
and
at the same time i got the msnbc show
and the current tv show and those are
done at the in parallel so we're
actually the oldest
online show period longest running daily
show on in internet history um and we're
the first partner ever for youtube
so we've now accumulated uh
20 billion views and 21 million
subscribers across all the platforms we
do everything from the same from
30-second videos to a 24-hour channel so
uh we have on on almost all the
platforms roku pluto samsung anywhere
you turn on just type in tyt you'll get
us and and your team wise how big is a
team today if you were to say young
turks as xyz employees how big would you
say the team is uh we're about 70 right
now okay and how much of that 70 is
talent
uh that's a good question well so it
depends on how you count because if you
count all of the part-time hosts then
we're at about a hundred
um so because we have about 30 people on
air right now um but off-air uh
like i said about 70. perfect i mean
that's uh
congratulations 20 billion is ridiculous
so when you're saying all this means you
stayed on you're survived that's the
that's the thing so uh you know for for
some that don't know how much has
changed in media obviously if anybody
can talk on that speak on the last 20
years uh it's you because you talk about
how listen i was a broke radio guy
trying to make money trying to figure
this thing out i busted my ass and
finally i got my break etc etc how much
have things changed the last 20 years
everything's changed everything so about
24 years ago i wrote uh to my friends an
email saying online video is gonna be tv
and so i'm gonna head to online video
right now because i'm positive that it's
this is in the 90s when aol is a thing
yeah 98 i wrote the email and what was
the foresight how did you even know that
that was gonna be a thing this is before
youtube yeah so
i i'd like to think that i'm a logical
guy and so i look at patterns and i see
where things are going and people are
always
unfortunate a lot of people just look
right in front of them right it's really
hard to see a couple steps ahead right
but if you logically look at something
you can clearly see where it's going so
look first of all television has these
massive costs
online video you saw that had no
gatekeepers and no overhead costs so or
very little overhead costs i'm like that
means there's going to be a million of
them and they're going to start to get
more and more popular and they're going
to serve the audience because they don't
have advertisers they have to serve the
audience first the problem with tv and
i've been in tv pitch meetings is that
they serve advertisers first so i'll be
in a tv pitch meeting and they'll say
okay what's walmart going to think
and i think okay this show's doomed
because walmart wants vanilla they do
not want
interesting programming at all
they don't want fights no bickering just
nothing no drama and by the way do they
say that to the
actual company like will they say this
is the kind of talent we're looking for
if you got a guy like this we'll
advertise during this time
well it's it's not about talent it's
about the shows so now now we're fast
forwarding a little bit right so when i
when i'm taking a tv pitch meeting now
we're in the middle of my career and
we're trying to pitch something from tyt
network to one of the tv stations and so
at that point they're not talking about
talent as much as the content of the
show what kind of show is it right and
so the minute you start talking politics
they're like whoa everybody's out yeah
everybody's out nobody wants it because
they live in the old world in the whole
world you're going to get 100 of the
audience 100 of the market you don't
want to offend anyone it's 1955. it's
okay there's only three tv stations you
put it on you shove your product down
their throats it's going to be fine the
new legacy media
media you know legacy advertisers by the
way
right now still the same thing i mean
it's not nearly as bad but unbelievable
i just read an article in digital just a
couple of days ago about how the brands
are still like whoa out of this
newfangled youtube thing i don't know
like you know just now yeah and there's
still advertising on tv there's no under
45 year olds on tv at all zero zero zero
zero right and and brands are killing
themselves they're just i i said on
twitter you're better off burning the
money in publicly because at least
people will watch okay nobody's gonna
watch you on tv and so look we have
24-hour channels and we're on the new tv
those ott platforms right what don't
they understand yet they're just an
old-school way of thinking they don't
want to give up what they had what is it
the advertising industry is the single
most conservative industry in america i
don't i don't mean politically i mean
just by nature so
and and one of the quotes was well
nobody's gotten fired doing this in the
last 20 years buying tv well that's the
problem you should all get fired you if
you're
a brand trying to appeal to younger
viewers
and you're on television and not online
everyone in your marketing team should
be fired
so you're just nuts if you're doing that
you're just burning the money
here's a question for you because uh
what it makes me think about is the fact
that
you know how justin bieber was found
where did usher find bieber on you
youtube or something like that some
story i don't know if you familiar with
this or not it was or even it was
scooter bronc uh scooter braun found him
and then and then he teamed him up with
that sure they did it even the guy from
uh what is that don't stop believing is
that journey yeah okay journey they
brought a filipino guy from the
philippines who was yeah you know it's
like this guy's got the sickest voice he
becomes the lead singer for
you know during a journey and they found
him on youtube
who would logan paul been 20 years ago
who would have a lot of these guys been
20 years ago like literally i'm
wondering like a lot of these guys that
are big vloggers today
big youtubers today who would they have
been 20 years ago
yeah i don't maybe they would have gone
on to mtv somehow uh and that would have
been the route that makes sense probably
but i'll tell you what guys
another reason why online video is
always going to win is because
um there's just
too many of them since there's no
gatekeepers the audience is gonna find
what they like so it democratizes media
so look i'm not a big fan of logan paul
but you put them on
and people there's a community that's
gonna say hey i like that guy okay
before you couldn't get past the
gatekeepers so the only people that were
allowed on were people that the
executives liked
so who do the executives like well they
like relatively rich people who say that
the status quo is great and you
shouldn't change anything and remember
we're doing a show for walmart so keep
it vanilla that's why tv was doomed the
most boring stuff on
in the world what they're doing
a domino show now i think
i mean they're watching domino's fall i
mean it's just sad yeah they're gonna do
finally the last tv show is just gonna
be bingo
[Laughter]
so but if you i mean if you think about
it again capitalism wins innovation wins
again because they were able to compete
against the traditional guys and the
traditional guys who don't want to do
any work and they're kind of bullying
the talent and saying you better do this
or else
now there's so much competition that you
can't do that anymore because yeah the
reality of it is the talent's going to
find a place to get their voice heard
this the market we're living in you
can't silence people today well some
people are trying to decide with certain
people but all i'm saying is if the
talent is a real talent he's going to
make it or she's going to make it if
they go and do the work that they that's
necessary let me bring up a quick point
with tv i want to get your thoughts on
this the other day with your dad
and we were looking for
the the march madness game
you're talking about the legacy media
there used to be three channels the big
three abc nbc cbs and i remember
whatever was the late 90s early 2000s
and all of a sudden it was like 50
channels it's like holy moly
i'm with pat's dad who's seventy nine
we're about to be eighteen days god
bless you gabriel
um
and we're looking for the game
and there's 900 channels he's like oh
yeah yeah i think it may be on 8 47
maybe it's on 140 like he knew the
channels he knew what was going on in
the sports how many of those do you
really watch that's what i'm saying is
that like it's so fractured it's you
talking about the democratization of
media how does that factor into that i
mean there's so many tv channels it's no
longer a big three what are your
thoughts on that yeah so real quick
couple of things there um number one
uh
yes because of the fracturing you will
not get the big three again you will get
relatively large companies vox buzzfeed
us right um
but there'll be a lot more talent spread
out and they can't nobody can stop that
so you're not gonna get as you're not
gonna get seinfeld or er like shows
where 25 30 million people are watching
at the same time that's like when
everyone tuned into dallas for the
finale and you got a hundred million
people like that doesn't exist anymore
probably not there's gonna be some
tentpole events super bowl
oscars kind of etc and new ones will pop
up uh but so that uh that's one of the
small downsides because then we're we
don't share the same culture anymore and
that's a much larger topic that we
should get into
but you know you kind of alluded to
cancer culture there i grew up in an era
of massive cancer culture and it was uh
progressives who got cancelled so i
remember sending a tape into a minnesota
radio station and then the program
director was decent enough to call me
back and said this is fantastic and he's
like and i'm like all right great what
time slot do you have available and he's
like none i said why he said you're on
the left all of my other programming is
on the right so i'm not going to count a
program in the middle of the day so
you know good luck to you kid because
you're really good what year was that
90s that was we had already started on
serious and they were allowing us to
pitch it to other radio stations so that
was around 2003. yeah i mean the
listening cancel culture hurts both
sides it's not just one set of some it's
it flip-flops though it goes one side
for 10 20 30 years and then whoever's in
charge then it goes to the other side
then it goes to the other side either
way we just want to hear people's
arguments yeah and let us let us as the
viewer make a decision what's right and
what's not yeah i think that there is
one clear line for sure there's an
arguable second line but advocating for
violence is unacceptable okay so that's
my clear line and so other than that
i've defended ben shapiro and coulter
when they're giving speeches on college
campuses i didn't think megyn kelly or
don imus or any of those people should
have been fired you s it doesn't serve
anyone to fire people it doesn't serve
the nation it doesn't serve the
conversation why don't you like when
megyn kelly made the comments about um
black or white santa claus or whatever
it was that uh no in in the nbc case it
was blackface right um she had made the
comments about santa claus when she was
on fox so nbc fires right obviously they
were just doing that because the ratings
weren't working out and they want to
dump the contract that's keeping it real
right but if they were serious and they
were just outraged at that suggestion
which is preposterous honestly then why
don't you have al roker who was really
mad about it and and other people come
on and have a national conversation with
megyn kelly that way people will learn
why blackface is offensive instead of
not having any idea all they know is
people just randomly get fired right
what about putting whoopi on two week
timeout because she had some unsavory
thoughts yeah that was
absolutely
absurd now having said that i still
think today a majority of the cancer
culture is on the right wing it's
started on the right wing it's still in
the right wing it's still in the right
yes absolutely how did it start how can
you say so the modern cancer culture
started with barry weiss which is
hilarious and ironic she went around the
country getting famous for trying to
fire professors who dared to talk about
palestinian human rights so if they said
palestinians were equal and should have
their own state she would try to get
them fired okay and so she started
canceled culture what year was that so
that was that's a good question
about 20 years ago i think without
the new york times what was she
no no it was before she was at the new
york times that's how she got famous i
thought she got friends they're not
pro-israel enough fire on fire and fire
you can look it up okay so she starts
cancer culture then she pretends that
she's a victim of it which by the way
she never was she was never fired from
anywhere she decided to quit the new
york times to make more money on her own
so look
the
what are the right ways you can't say
behind closed doors you can't write this
you can't do this i mean that stuff
happens just like it happened to you
when you're over there saying you've got
to talk more like a senator you get
whatever word they use with your
senatorial when you're speaking like oh
it's editorial right so that kind of
stuff is probably what you know robbed
heard the wrong way yeah do you agree
with him that the cancel culture is
mostly coming from that right i'd love
to know i'd love to know i i do agree
with him in in the past i do agree with
him in the past but in the past you know
the media model was a different model
you had the walter cronkite of the world
you didn't have a lot of what you have
today today is more showmanship i mean
things changed after morton downey jr
after a lot of these guys that were more
showmans and then guys started realizing
that i'm going to get eyeballs so morton
downey jr you know who yeah
and next thing you know he's number one
ahead of montel ahead of ricky lake
ahead of uh
oprah winfrey ahead of jerry wait what
who are you in 18 months so people said
this is how i get to the top fast rather
than the old william buckley so today
our guest is uh jenka yuguru we're going
to talk to him about it
but for tv so but so so now people are
sitting there saying okay that's what
sells fantastic i'm going to go do this
just like rap change music change the
shock factor you know like when ice cube
wrote the song do you know
what was it not nwa he had a song about
cops
uh
yeah so so then next thing you know it's
like okay this is this the ride i'm
gonna take easy those guys changed hip
hop right uh so i can see that but but
the part i want to go with today is so
you say cancer culture still on the
right would you i think you would agree
that mainstream media outside of fox is
pretty much on the left i don't think
you wouldn't debate that no actually i
would debate okay so
tell me why yeah um so uh i can give you
a thousand examples but first of all
structure wise
if you say cnn etc msnbc are socially
liberal i'd say i generally agree with
you okay if you say they're economically
liberal i'd laugh and laugh and laugh no
they're economically conservative and
massively conservative so cnn for
example non-stop can i curse on here of
course
non-stop shits all over medicare for all
every time they talk about it oh
medicare for all it costs 34 trillion
dollars hey liar 32 trillion dollars hey
liars why don't you actually also say
that same study first of all paid for by
coke industries
said that it saves 34 trillion so
overall it saves 2 trillion
why do you leave out that context they
leave out that context every time
anytime you talk about a progressive
economic position and you go back to the
debates and see the smug anderson
coopers jake tappers looking down their
nose at bernie sanders going how are you
going to pay for that when we start
massive wars they never ask how you're
going to pay for that when we do massive
tax cuts for the rich they never ask how
are you going to pay for that no they're
definitely economically conservative and
what explains the dichotomy then why are
they socially liberal but economically
conservative because they're corporate
media so what do corporations want why
are they socially liberal because they
want to sell to everyone so i remember
being at a google presentation once and
coke was doing an ad and it was their
not their u.s ad but their international
ad and i was
shocked by how many muslims they had in
the ad right now i'm grow up muslim so
i'm not against it i'm great that's
wonderful it's inclusive etc right but i
was just like wow like a third of this
ad is muslims right then i was like
hello a third of the world is muslims
roughly right and so are they going to
be anti-muslim of course internationally
internationally of course not they got
to sell to 1.6 billion muslims are they
going to be against black people of
course not they got to sell the black
people gay people same thing right so
that's why corporate america and
multinational corporations are socially
liberal but economically they're
viciously conservative they because they
are structured to maximize profit i get
that part and you're right which by the
way that to me
uh uh that to me
eventually um ends up making them honest
if anything it forces them to be honest
and i know you may disagree with that
but at the same time i think it's fair
to say that anybody
to the right of you is considered
conservative like you you're probably
more on the bernie sanders camp you've
supported it so as a socialist even a
democrat is a conservative to you even a
center left that joe manchin is
conservative to you even a christian
cinema is conservative to you even even
an obama is probably conservative to you
probably a bite is conservative to you
probably hillary clinton is conservative
to you so then if i were to ask you who
would you say
is a liberal in your eyes to the outside
of bernie sanders who would you say
these are some of the liberals today so
let's clarify a couple things so first
of all uh it's much to the
annoyance of my audience i am not a
socialist i'm a capitalist so i'm what i
call a democratic capitalist which i
could explain right please and so
and and to be fair it's not the whole
audience at all the audience generally
likes what i'm saying obviously right
they're our audience right uh but there
is some portion of the left that the
word capitalist uh really uh grinds
their gears yeah i was almost going to
say christ said yes i was like
anyway um they they don't they don't
like that but i can explain why i i
believe that but in terms of the your
core question of are those people
conservative they're not just
conservative to me manchester cinema
obviously giant conservatives but
honestly biden is a huge conservative
and i can but it's not just to me and by
the way i can show it to you i can show
it to you that's why your policies and
in the polling but it's not just to me
guys i can show you in the polling that
two-thirds of the country is progressive
and if the if if they got beyond the
filter of both right-wing media and
mainstream media corporate media overall
they would think binders way too right
wing okay and so and and i actually
can't believe that anybody would think
he's a liberal i can't believe it he's
and so
who's uh actually progressive and and
progressive and liberal are different
now a lot of the left views the word
liberal as a little bit derisive like
it's neoliberal like the word liberal is
almost too conservative so many times
you yeah but the word liberal like the
word socialism is almost meaningless
because everybody thinks it's something
else when they're talking about it same
with conservative too yeah
well
you tell me because i i you know for me
conservative is is pretty clear but
maybe i'm wrong about that and i'm sure
there's gradations right so but
progressive is the left right so
uh sure aoc bernie sanders i i uh
co-founded just democrats so
uh all the squad jamal bowman corey bush
i love those are progressive those are
your guys those are the people you
support yeah okay so go back and when
you said
you know you believe the cnns the
msnbc's they're more right-wing socially
liberal but you know fiscally
conservative fine at the same time some
may say uh jank uh you know even though
you're taking that position
if you want to see a channel bashing a
musk you'll see them doing it if you
want to see a channel bashing capitalism
and you know what the wealth you're
doing you'll see them doing it if you'll
never if you want to see a channel
bashing a trump or a desantis or any uh
candidate on the right you'll see on cnn
and msnbc that's true so though somebody
may say well that's where they are the
every candidate that i put up say the
writers saying this every candidate i
put up desantis
trump you know nikki haley they keep
passions right so someone may say
they're far left you're saying they
don't do that no so you think you think
cnn msnbc mainstream media supports
trump in the city no not at all okay so
let me explain because you mentioned a
couple of different people there and
that's why i wanted to clarify sure so
are they against trump of course that's
uh that's super obvious are they against
desantis yes they are okay because they
view who are they for they're for the
establishment they're for the status quo
when you're a multi-billion dollar
corporation you know why you like the
status quo because you're at the top you
don't want to change anything when
you're at the time okay but when you say
nikki haley you're actually wrong nikki
haley cross over to establishment and
they love the establishment so for
example chris christie establishment
republican
abc cnn all giving multi-million dollar
documentary advertising all around chris
christie wait why is abc and cnn doing
these giant specials on chris christie
out of nowhere he hasn't done anything
in years and years and years because
they love establishment republicans all
my life i've watched meet the press
blow john mccain and every republican
that's ever kind of oh the beloved john
mccain which war would you like to start
now senator that's such a great idea
let's start another one tax cuts for the
rich why that's brilliant let's have
another guest on he agrees this is a
democrat you know and you fill in the
blank
claire mccaskill joe mansion it doesn't
matter look at that they also agree with
tax cuts for the rich well i guess
everybody we're all agreed tax cuts for
the rich so they don't like trump
because he's a he's a populist i think
that he's a fake populist but at least
he's playing that route and he's wild
he's out of control and he leads to
instability so the establishment does
not like that so the only person they
dislike more than trump is bernie
they would burn down the house before
they were like it's amazing how if you
remember this when this was going on a
year and a half ago when i was
upset that they didn't let bernie win
because
when i said so do you remember the day
where it it all it kind of all happened
like within 24-48 hours we're almost
done oh okay this guy's ahead no this
person's ahead no amy this no elizabeth
warren this no pete this no uh bernie
sanders says no everyone's dropping out
and they're getting behind joe biden
like wait what i can tell you exactly
how that happened yeah i mean i remember
but go ahead yeah so bernie won the
first three states now look mainstream
media is not in the they don't they're
not in the business of manufacturing
news they're in the business of
manufacturing consent okay so noam
chomsky wrote about this decades ago and
he's absolutely right so they do
propaganda for a living it's the
marketing arm of corporate rule so when
bernie won the first three states they
did not do what they always do when an
establishment candidate either a
republican or democrat wins the first
three states everybody in media goes oh
my god we have the presumptive winner
everybody clear the field clear the
field iowa new hampshire it's over right
they do that even when hillary clinton
loses one of them even before there was
any election they were like hillary
clinton's obviously the winner hillary
clinton leading in fact i criticized cnn
on cnn for doing this they used to count
her delegates which were the
establishment democratic politicians
before a single vote was in so they're
like hillary clinton has a 500 to
nothing lead on bernie sanders why is
bernie sanders still in the race right
so bernie wins the first three they're
like oh yeah whatever okay no big deal i
mean he's not necessarily going to win
he's i mean he's unelectable he's
unelectable but they panicked internally
they panicked and then you saw chucked
out and others come out and go oh
bernie's brown shirts and and by the way
these are this is on msnbc so-called
liberal channel right uh and then chris
matthews came on and said oh you know
people like bernie wins uh people are
gonna get shot in central park uh and
and i remember when castro was
threatening to do that etc they go they
they all pylon and the worst of the
worst was msnbc they're a wolf in
sheep's clothing so they come in oh
we're liberal we're on the left oh my
god but bernie's unelectable no
progressive was electable oh we brought
in claire mccaskill to be our expert
wait didn't she get her ass handed to
her even though she was an incumbent she
ran all the way right wing trying to
copy the republicans it's a losing
strategy every single time but msnbc
loves it because it's economically
conservative and by the way i have
personal experience at msnbc i i partly
got moved out of prime time because i
was criticizing barack obama and they
hated that and they literally told me so
there's no question that they are
economically right away so so then so
then for me this is how i see it i see
bernie and trump as the same people uh
and i know you may not agree with this
or you may not like this but i should i
see them as same people let me explain
to you why because i think uh
the left like i'm surprised the right
didn't do to trump with the left it to
bernie i'm very surprised they didn't
they tried every single way to get this
guy to not be the candidate because they
don't have control over the guy the
people they fear is whoever they don't
control you can't control bernie you
can't control trump that's why i think
they're the same i don't sit there and i
agree with bernie's policies i'm not a
socialist i escaped around to not have
to deal with the high taxes and to
control all that that's the fear that a
lot of immigrants that leave their own
countries who come here and i know
you're one as well but that's what a lot
of people from you know that in this
capitalist they don't want to deal with
that so on the other side with trump he
was a loose cannon he's getting out
there calling out they're pretty much
calling out the same people trump and
bernie are calling out the establishment
they're both calling out some of the
same swamps same people even though
bernie's a lot more part of the swamp
you know a lot of people on the right
will say he's never had a real job all
this other stuff and a lot of people on
the uh left will say trump's never been
involved in politics what the hell does
he know about getting policies on all
this other stuff you'll hear some of
those things but that's why i think
those two were the same but even going
back to it so if you say well yeah you
know cnn and you know all these guys
they're still fiscally on the right
you know desantis has got tens of
millions of eyeballs right now people
that follow the guy and he may be their
next superstar you know even on uh trump
you got 78 million eyeballs whatever the
number is that he got the votes picker
81 is it 8178 i don't i don't know if
i'm getting the numbers right or not but
so he's got 78 million eyeballs
if you're not going to give that guy any
credit and so this will go to my next
question with you know i'm really
curious what you're going to say with
this
so
everybo i think a lot of times and maybe
this is a left and a right thing but for
the last six years it was more of a left
thing left media side
they did not know if russia was real but
man they kept talking about it like a
broken record they had no clue if this
thing was real but thank god they had
some story to talk about every day
viewership another thing with russia
another you know
who's the one guy that got up shift
what's shift's first time adam schiff
but i'm getting oh my god he's saying it
there's got to be something that's like
what are you talking about and then next
thing you know you find out that uh with
the report that came out that uh what's
the report that came out with the
mueller not the mueller the other one
that just
spying on the durham report that comes
out hey this is really what was going on
well we don't really know this and then
they stopped talking about it and then
you see the hunter biking laptop you
know
everybody's like no this is just medium
misinformation another republican
misinformation another russian
misinformation campaign
and then folks are sitting there and i'm
looking at cnn's eyeballs so folks are
sitting there saying
who the hell do you believe today do you
believe them do you believe who do you
believe today it's very hard
for the regular viewer and a listener
that's not involved in the politics like
you are that they've committed their
life to that this is their work it's the
average guy that's like listen i'm just
trying to see who i believe you know you
seem you know inconsistent you seem
consistent you seem consistent you seem
inconsistent who the hell do i believe
that's why i say i think
i think cnn msnbc a lot of the
mainstream media lost a lot of people
because all they want to defend is
maybe not progressives but democrats on
the left and they don't want to support
anything that the republicans are
talking about and they lost a lot of
people so i got to flip your frame here
because you're
you're right on so many things but it's
just the wording is off and and it makes
a big big deal speak english is time
give me a break it's my fifth language
by the way not my first language either
um so
here's what i mean by that it seems like
they're supporting democrats but they're
not like
i gave you the example of chris christie
i gave the example john mccain i can
give you tons of clarification yeah tons
of corporate republicans that the
establishment press supports as well
now they're but yes they're mainly in
love with corporate democrats that is
true okay because corporate democrats
unfortunately it's it pains me and
that's why i fight them so much have
become the most corporate right uh we
will do whatever corporations say and
we'll pretend that there's change on the
outside oh my god we've got a black
person who's doing everything
corporations want so everything is fixed
no everything is not fixed so for
example 15 minimum wage is so important
to the black community
47 of blacks in this country make less
than 15 an hour right what what do debt
corporate democrats do they put out
somebody like hakeem jeffries to say now
he goes oh i'm for the 15 minute wage
but behind the scenes he helps to kill
the 15 minimum wage but as long as we
got the right face on it corporate rule
is awesome no it is not awesome so it's
not that they're pro democrat it's that
their pro corporate rule and and and so
the populism that you're seeing the
similarity between trump and bernie
you're right you're not right it's not
they don't they're not similar on
policies of course not right and they're
not and they're not similar on on
earnestness like bernie's super earnest
i think trump is a grade a con man right
but they are both cannot be controlled
that is true and that is why
establishment media despises them and so
establishment media has lied to us our
entire lives can i can you draw a
correlation to what you're saying
because the control neither of you two
can be controlled and i think that's
something that you both can agree upon
is that you'd like to be able to say
what the hell ever you want to say do
what you want to do in america exactly i
mean that that's undeniable
who wants to be controlled but you made
a couple of points here and i just want
to kind of put the align the stars and
see if i'm right here essentially what
you're talking about
is old school versus new school now you
brought up the we started off the
conversation with media and the
establishment media and legacy media
versus new media and the democratization
of media then you moved on to
establishment politics versus
basically the trumps and the bernies and
the aocs or
you know messing up the establishment
and i'll even go one further that's
essentially what crypto is doing to
you know uh
typical mainstream you know the monetary
system essentially what is happening is
here is the establishment wants to
control what they establi what they
control yeah you know and and what
you're basically saying and what whether
you're bernie guy or a trump guy is
they're rattling a lot of cages
and the establishment don't like that
too much yeah 100
and patrick let me just go back to
agreeing with you on the core premise
which is really important right so
the reason why people are looking to
these alternatives now the trumps the
bernie's everything else and our
programming all the different right-wing
left-wing etcetera is because the one
thing we all know for sure and i'll give
the right-wing credit on this they know
this better than the left-wing does okay
uh is that the politicians are full of
[ __ ] okay and
and what do what has establishment media
told us our whole lives the politicians
are honest they're having real debates
they're all really principled and
they're honorable and you have to
respect them and they're worthy of so
much respect whereas we look at them and
go but that's that guy is obviously
lying that guy is obviously cheesy that
guy's the most plastic person i have
ever met that's why in 2016 everybody in
the press said it's going to be jeb bush
or marco rubio and i said you guys are a
joke there's no chance it's going to be
that marco rubio is a boy okay he's the
most plastic fake politician you'll ever
meet in your entire life and that's why
corporate media loved him they loved him
they're like it's got to be rubio it's
got to be a ruby i'm like have you guys
looked at a single goddamn poll i said
trump would win the republican primary
about four months before they started
voting you know why i'm not a genius one
i just know the country's in a populist
mood they hate the lies of the
establishment media about how
politicians are so goddamn wonderful
because that's just the most obvious lie
of all time right and secondly i could
read a poll and every poll had trumpet
number one by a lot and they're like no
don't believe you're lying guys by the
way every poll in 2016 had bernie
beating trump and by large margins and
hillary clinton was losing to trump and
every day abc cbs nbc all of them would
come out and lie to the american people
and say hillary clinton could beat trump
hillary clinton is better at beating
trump than bernie hillary clinton is
more electable every one of them was
alive you think bernie could have beaten
trump it's not me it's the american
people the polling indicated he clearly
could have beaten trump on election day
now i know they didn't run an election
against each other right on election day
bernie was beating trump by 12 points so
you run an election the republican smear
him you're going to wear down that 12
right
but you're not going to wear down the
whole 12 12 is a giant monster league do
you remember those polls pat i'm not
that saying that polls are credible but
i mean that's a whole nother first of
all first of all first of all what we
learned about polls in 2015-2016 none of
them are right so the the credibility of
the only poll
i may give some credence to is i i look
at pew is good gallup is relatively
trusting any fox news poll cnn poll
msnbc i don't i don't look at any of
that stuff those are the only two i pay
attention to but folks if you're
listening to this super chats we're
going to come to some of the questions a
few people make comments here adriano
valentino from australia said trump is
an uncomfortable con man question mark
sink you're a sociopath the next guy
responds and says at least he's a con
man at least he's not a politician which
is pretty ambitious well that last one's
kind of true yeah at least he's a
professional yeah so so we'll we'll take
collins uh in the last 30 minutes
probably so just stay tuned and tyler if
you want to put the number there for
some people that want to call in in the
super chats but let me continue okay so
can i address the con man thing real
quick sure of course i mean look he's
been adjudicated and admitted to being a
con man uh both his charity and his
university were giant scams and he had
to pay huge fines 25 million dollar fine
because he was running scams almost
everything he runs as a scam and by the
way does everybody know that he's gone
bankrupt six times that he's an awful
awful businessman couldn't manage his
way out of a wet paper bag
biggest dumb ass i've ever seen in
business what he did in atlantic city it
didn't just sink his own companies he
sank the entire city he's one of the
worst businessmen in american history
and by the way you see the incompetence
of the democratic party that they
couldn't point out those simple facts
when they were running let me ask you
this what's harder to do okay be honest
let's see i'm really curious what you're
gonna say you think it's harder to be a
senator for 50 years or do you think
it's harder to be in free enterprise
free market capitalism competition in
new york for 50 years what's harder to
do uh well trump has proved that uh the
economy is much harder because he went
bankrupt so many times it must be really
really hard
but but wait wait a minute but the point
is it is it is a there's a big
difference between me being in the arena
and getting my ass kicked but at least
i'm getting in the arena versus being a
fan on the outside and i'm booing the
guy in the arena let's give some
credibility to the guy that's got the
balls to be in the arena fighting
free market patrick i give you credit i
give me credit yeah we're in the arena
and we built these things on our own
okay so ben shapiro i don't agree with
his politics but he built daily wire and
it's a real business now it said i give
credit okay crowder i don't think takes
big uh money and i think he did it on
his own i give a lot of credit trump had
his dad hand him 413 million dollars
he's a spoiled little [ __ ] okay and he
blew the whole 413 million dollars
because he's a [ __ ] i give him zero
credit kids yes okay when you when your
kids when you die and you have a living
trust you're a smart guy i'm sure you
got a living trust i'm sure you got all
that stuff in place when god forbid
something happens to you and that money
and the business goes to them are you
going to call your kills they spoiled
whatever whatever because they're going
to get your money no no no no there's a
difference what do you do with the money
so if my kids then use it to do good in
the world or to set up a business etc
then that's great if they take it and
they go daddy gave me the money i'm
going to put my name all over atlantic
city
and then they are spoiled and they
make fun of other people while actually
not doing anything not doing the
homework i can't even read
i'd be embarrassed if my kids were
anywhere near as lazy and dumb as donald
trump they can't read past the page they
used to have the presidential briefings
that were just three four pages they had
to boil it down to a page because he
would lose attention because because the
because uh but because the guy is
dealing with so many different things
that he typically wants to have the one
page instead of the 50 pages but no less
can i make a quick point on trump yeah
okay this might shock some of the people
i'm not a trump fan i don't know you
know probably not my politics i mean
there's a lot of people here that think
i'm a crazy socialist left-wing because
i'm just not a trump fan i'm a
capitalist and i like what you said
about democratic capitalism i'd like to
come back to that at some point but
again not a trump fan
but what i am willing to do is at least
give him credit for some positive things
that he's done
as an example
you're giving him zero credit bro i will
say as much as i don't like seeing him
on tv he's a great marketer i can say
that guy is a freaking brilliant
marketer he gets eyeballs he knows how
to play the media he knows how to rattle
cages like i'm at least willing to give
him credit for the things he does well
and even if it's for policies i'll say
look can't stand the guy but policies
wise he's done some good things are you
saying that there's zero credits zero
whatsoever
no i'm not saying that everything is
situational people get into uh which
camp are you in are you left right biden
pro biden antibiotic so for example i
think biden's doing a great job on
ukraine i think he did a terrible job on
domestic politics total failure in
domestic politics so we can get back
into that later so why because it
depends on the facts so trump i remember
in the beginning there was a plan in
indiana and he threatened a bunch of
politicians and he threatened a bunch of
businesses and it looked like they were
going to stay and i remember doing a
video at an airport because i i liked
that so much because then msnbc was
crying oh my god can you believe he's
threatening people that god damn right
the president's supposed to use carrots
and sticks and he was using sticks
effectively now unfortunately
that one as with almost all of them was
just marketing and then that plant
actually outsourced all the jobs later
and trump didn't do a goddamn thing
about it it's all fake etc so but if on
rare occasions that but for example he
didn't start any new wars great i'll
take it i'll take it right there's no
reason for me to disagree with someone
if they're agreeing with me
oh it's because it's trump you have to
call it bad no that doesn't make any
sense you show me a sensible policy and
i'll be fair enough by the way i i and
i've said this many times i will say it
again i think sanders is a true believer
if you get married in russia and you go
to no not russia but i think he went as
honeymoon to uh leningrad or st
petersburg or something like that he
went to russia this guy is a true
believer from day one and he stayed
there so maybe not a communist pretty
close to it socialist my opinion i may
be wrong but the guy's been a true
believer here's what i'm convinced with
and tell me if if you feel this way or
not because this goes back to you saying
you know how he's done with ukraine
biden's done a good job with ukraine and
i want to kind of push back on that
challenge a little bit and see if your
uh views are different on this which if
it is the audience going to win so
here's what i'm convinced with i've not
been following politics my entire life
i'm a business guy i've been in
insurance i've started with morgan
stanley day before 9 11. i was in the
military three years my mother was a
communist they grew up to communist
manifesto that's what they saw as a hero
who he was what he did karl marx my
dad's an imperialist he was a shaw guy
so i saw them battling it out all the
time and being a kid one time my mom
i think was 13 14 years old i'm having
an econ class and my teacher miss lou
starts talking about the politicians and
democrats and republicans and the
defendant and i come i said mom are we
democrats or republicans and my mom says
we're democrats i said why are we
democrats she says because the democrats
are for the poor republicans are for the
rich i said when i grow up i want to be
republican one day meaning i want to be
rich i don't because i hated being poor
i'm a welfare baby parents got a divorce
dad worked at a 99 cent store but here's
here's what i'm convinced that's going
on when i watch some of these things
okay from my experience
i started following politics say uh
carry error whatever the carry arrow is
i don't know if it's all four
oh three or four right when i started
okay where i kind of had to start paying
attention to it
um
i don't know why i may be wrong chunk
and give me your perspective on this
who's been on this for a long time
i'm convinced
both party doesn't like a candidate that
they don't have dirt on
let me explain
i'm convinced
they don't like it
if
they don't have three things on you
where they know for a fact they can
control you
then you become a leading candidate
meaning
maybe bernie sanders is not a good
candidate because we ain't got [ __ ] on
this guy guy doesn't party the guy
doesn't do this the guy doesn't we can't
control this guy okay but biden that's
the best candidate because dude we got a
[ __ ] ton of things on this guy hell yeah
we can control this guy right or obama
look i think we can control this guy why
maybe we got a couple things on obama
but obama doesn't have money so maybe
money is going to drive him so if we
give him opportunities to be a celebrity
to be this to be that maybe that's a
driver so then you look at a guy like on
the right
and you say trump
well we got a lot of dirt on this guy
let's throw it all out there all right
let's see if this is oh we're going to
destroy this guy stormy daniels ah never
happened
he's like no it happened she goes on
jimmy kimmel you know michael avenatti
oh yo yo you know what karen mcdougall
he i actually thought he loved me and we
would actually spend time and he told me
once he loves me he never disrespected
me you're like man i believe she seems
very believable oh you know here's how
many people african-americans you know
housing what he did
yeah it was a long time ago well here's
here's what happened yeah it's not true
well here's bush recording what you said
you know gravity yeah no no
well you know it's just locker room talk
i think they used every dirt they had on
trump then they had nothing afterwards
then they said [ __ ] now we got to
fabricate stuff so for example cuomo i'm
convinced i may be wrong push back
because i want to get smart in this area
i'm convinced that cuomo
was somebody
that was talking at a game on the
democratic party and he looked at this
guy and they said hey cuomo we got a lot
of stuff on you behind closed doors bro
you better shut your mouth and kind of
do what we're telling you to do get a
little bit too big and you're starting
to get more eyeballs than everybody else
and you have more voice now because
everything you do in your life or
whatever he was doing during code
remember that whole thing that you
almost felt like he's the president not
trump being a president and i said ah we
can't control this guy boom get him out
of there it's not like they had dirt on
this guy they could have used those
things a long time ago so
maybe i'm naive okay and maybe i think
the reason why biden got elected is
because the democratic party had the
most dirt on that candidate more than
anybody else am i wrong
so it's not right or wrong it's off by a
shade if you ask me okay i think the
essence of it is right
but but the way again where the way
you're framing it is a tiny bit off so
let me explain from my point of view
please okay so
um
the the candidates that agree with them
they don't need to
use any find any dirt or use any dirt
right so pete budages will do anything a
corporation asks him to do okay so he's
a robot made in a corporate factory
somewhere and so you don't ever need to
dig up dirt on buddha juice in fact at
tyt we went and did investigations of
how he ran his little town in indiana
and it was awful and it was by the way
rife with racism now did you see any of
the mainstream media use that no but if
buddha judge had gone progressive they'd
have picked up our stories instantly and
said look at this racist guy can you
believe what he did he fired some uh
black police chief for complaining about
that they would have gone nuts but they
choose not to use that by lied about
going to
help nelson mandela in in south africa
he went he went but he said he got
arrested with nelson mandela that is not
at all true okay and the mainstream
media just let it go they had that dirt
they never ever ever used it why because
biden agreed with the corporate agenda
now when you don't agree with the
corporate agenda then it's not that they
already have the dirt they'll go find
the dirt and then they'll use it and if
they can't find dirt they'll just make
it up how do i know it happened to me
let alone bernie let alone trump let
alone anyone who doesn't agree with the
corporate agenda what they used to do
patrick in the old days was
assassinations right so
like jfk etc and people say oh no it was
really a guy on you know the rv is sure
sure sure okay don't be absurd
you see that's manufacturing consent
when they get you to believe that a
bullet can move it at angles that it
cannot physically possibly move right so
um but these days they don't need to do
that that's messy instead what they do
is character assassinations okay so you
get a little too close to power and you
don't already agree with the mainstream
corporate way of thinking you will be
eliminated that's when they dig up the
dirt use the dirt manufacture the dirt
so in my case i ran for congress
and the new york times all of a sudden
painted me as a right winger by the way
i just checked time to see i just i'm
sorry i'm not checking i take time to
see what we got what do you have after
this can you go uh uh
okay so so we're gonna go longer than
our two hour usual so we're not wrapping
up at 11 o'clock so go ahead you were
saying yeah
so for in my case the new york times
said uh anti-muslim
wait a minute i
i'm atheist now but i grew up muslim my
family's muslim my background is what do
you mean i'm anti-muslim it doesn't
matter we're smearing you
didn't you don't you want to at least
say oh it's kind of interesting or
ironic or etc because he's actually from
a muslim background no they didn't even
say that right then the alt-right had
done the smear campaign against me where
they took a joke about uh bestiality and
pretended it was real like i had said it
real new york times writes it like as if
it's in my agenda jenk who's believes in
legalizing sex with horses
there's the new york times are you
insane
did no one in the building think hey
guys that sounds like it's probably a
joke like you guys want to double check
but they're like no no just write it as
if it's in this platform right that's an
alt-right total toxic sludge horse crab
that the new york times printed why
because they don't want a progressive
winning they can't control me la times
and then of course then they said i had
david duke on the show i called him a
racist an anti-semit
anti-semite a bigot i called him every
name of the book new york times says he
had david duke on the program to share
his anti-semitic views oh come on no
they're liars they're lying to you
because when someone you know you don't
think you don't think everybo so for
example let me put it back i don't know
but you don't think people will say well
jank that's not fair because you guys do
that at young turks would you say we
never do that at young turks we never do
that
so so you don't take one snippet of
let's just say what i don't know what a
uh ann says or or who anna's not that
much in tv today
you're saying coulter or let's just say
shapiro or whoever you say look what he
said in this part and you don't show the
whole thing so i'll give you an example
yeah when mccain all the way back in
2008 because we've been around forever
uh a local arizona station had done an
edited video of mccain's talk and it
made him look really bad
we thought
it was not edited we thought it was real
we aired it one day the next day our
audience says to us hey you know that
was edited here's the whole thing we
come back the next day we say our bad
we trusted that local station they were
wrong they took mccain out of context we
don't like mccain at all but you always
have to be fair and he didn't say that
look at the context of what he actually
said right so if you show me a clip
where i'm missing context i will
definitely show that on air and go wait
a minute let's look at the whole thing
here because we don't need to lie to be
right okay well there is the reason that
that mainstream media has to lie
is because people want higher wages they
don't want lower wage people want health
care they don't want to have their
family member get cancer not be able to
be treated so they have to lie to push
their agenda and their
maximizing profit is a hell of a thing
and so
it to come all the way back to
democratic capitalism capitalism in is
the right incentive structure but it
must be checked by democracy if it is
not checked by democracy it will run
completely out of control and right now
that's exactly what's happened the the
corporations have seized the media and
have used it to brainwash the american
people into compliance so when that's
why i say on that core issue i get that
the right wing is in some ways more
right and more animated than the left
wing is because they see that control
and they hate it and that's why they
always talk about freedom and they don't
like the mass mandates they don't like
the vaccines but they're just getting
misdirected now it's the perfect example
is under obama uh the the p the tea
party started because they were so mad
about the bank bailouts right wing you
were right you were right the bank
bailouts were monstrous they were
horrible they were total robbery of the
american people and the koch industry
saw that and they're like good let's
take advantage of these
guys so they brought in their buses we
covered it coke industries paid for
buses paid for meals
and they didn't bring them to a protest
of the banks they brought them to a
protest of obamacare to try to defeat
them getting more health care
wait a minute what the hell just
happened it was corporations that took
your anger
and directed it to their benefit it was
amazing listen that's that's the and by
the way
the koch brothers have a very uh
respectable competitor his name is
george soros i don't know if you've
heard of him before he plays a similar
card as well so it's not like he's a
an angel going out there he's got
competition so it's not like coco are
sitting there alone by themselves but
what i will say is the following when
that happened that's the part with
capitalism that i have a problem with
because
when it comes down to somebody doesn't
run the business properly either let
them go out of business or let somebody
else buy them out very simple by the way
most people forget women do you remember
wamu i don't know if you remember women
did you did you bank with women i mean i
remember wamu you know was blowing up
you'd go into the bank guamo and you'd
stand up and you'd actually see the
banker you're like [ __ ] i'm actually
talking to somebody versus that whole
you feel like you're going to the dmv
with a fake four-inch class thing you're
talking to her okay i like wangu style
right you know wama went from zero to
330 billion dollar company 330 billion
dollar you can pull this up right now
but wamu just type in one 330 billion
dollars okay
type in woman 330 billion dollars you'll
see some article that'll come out uh uh
uh
let me see where you have wamuwamu bank
uh uh uh one of washington mutuals maybe
he needs to put that see go a little bit
closer so we can see it
go back you will see somewhere that says
330 billion dollars
yeah so woman was a 330 billion auto
company right do you know what it ended
up selling for do you know what chase
bottom for do you know the number
chase pad wamu for 1.9 billion dollars
okay from 330 billion to 1.9 billion
dollars guess what a lot of those
companies want to unmute yourself
because we're here in the typing title
so they went from 330 to 1.9 but at that
time guess what
they're not letting that happening let's
go too big to fail i'm sorry they maybe
made some bad choices let them fail and
have somebody else buy him out
that's when the argument from the left
or folks like yourself
has some credence because you'll see
favors being done for the bigger guys
that you're not letting them go out of
business you kind of got to do it at the
same time i'll flip it as well and kind
of debate myself
on this point where a guy named boben
moshe i don't know if you remember bob
benmosche aig baba moshe used to be the
ceo of uh uh yeah there you go uh
330 billion dollars of assets you see
that 327.9 and it sold for 1.9 billion
dollars and if you go highlight the 1.9
billion dollars right there uh go up
four lines five lines to the left boom
chase bottom for 1.9 billion
dollars is what they pay for can you
imagine it's like that's like a 330
dollar thing you buy for a dollar 90
cents pretty insane for that to happen
but bobbin moshe was retired he had
cancer he was dying it was a former sea
of metlife and aig calls him up and says
we want you to come and be to see us
like listen i'm dying i got three years
left to live he had acne everywhere
because he was taking the steroid shots
and all this stuff so it was
uncomfortable because this is a good
looking six four six five he could talk
he talks [ __ ] and he talked to you like
a man's man he didn't talk to like the
typical wall street guys right and i've
been in many meetings have many dinners
with this guy and they call him and he
says um i'm in dubrovnik at my winery if
you want me i'll do it for 10 million
dollars not a penny less this that's a
lot of money says let me explain to what
i'm like i'm like a prostitute except
the very expensive one that's his line
right anyways they bring him in he goes
to the government gets 183 billion
dollars pays it back within a few years
and pays it back with 21 billion dollars
of interest and the next thing you know
he dies literally right after they paid
back everything this guy dies he says
here i was on my deathbed okay and if
you read his book on his deathbed his
wife's two is right his girlfriend's to
his left okay the wife that he left
anyways but they weren't together it was
divorced but the point is yeah everybody
loved this guy he was one of those he
was a man's man leader this is where i'm
going with this
i'm watching msnbc and i don't know this
guy's uh you know who he is he's always
on he's a business uh uh he's on the
business guy business side
and he's interviewing elizabeth warren
yesterday okay and i'm sure you know
what elizabeth warren stick is you've
heard it and you probably agree with
some of it right
where she says you know
elon musk he's this he's a freeloader
you know i don't know if you saw that or
not he was on with uh what's his name
uh uh uh oh yeah he does the thing with
andrew sorkin in the morning you know
who he is
that's cnbc nbc yeah so so anyway so
he's calling around and he says hey so
oh he's a freeload elon musk is a free
loan he says
shouldn't we celebrate this capitalist
he's one of us he loves america he came
here he created all these jobs should we
not recognize though he took money from
so what's your position would warren
musk that conversation so this is the
what drives me crazy about the national
conversation none of it makes any sense
so
uh
are you for elon musk or against elon
musk wait a minute that question doesn't
make any sense the question is what's
elon musk doing so if you say are you
for tesla well that creates electric
cars and that's going to help to climb
it and i'm in favor of that so that's
great so that's a great thing that that
elon musk is doing
but but in terms of paying taxes for
decades he barely paid any taxes
so wait why would i be in favor of that
billionaires on average right now and
federal taxes pay about eight percent
because of all the loopholes
am i in favor should i like some
progressives will say there shouldn't be
any billionaires i don't agree with that
right so you you did a great job you
built a great business it helped the
world generally you became a billionaire
fantastic right but should you pay your
taxes [ __ ] yeah you should pay your
taxes so no when when elizabeth warren
says they should pay their taxes
otherwise they're a freeloader
she's absolutely right so let's unpack
that let's unpack that okay so this this
takes me to one area where
uh i may have we may have different
opinions but i kind of want to process
it with you so here's here's how i look
at it
if the government has a million dollars
to give to you or to give to the
government on who's going to do better
job with the money i trust you're
probably going to make the million
dollars into 2 million more than the
government's going to turn a million
dollars into 2 million okay now you may
disagree and you may say pat i disagree
with that but they gave this guy 464
million dollars
the scanning milan was the freeloader
right
and he takes that 400 million dollars
and
it's a 10-year loan that they give him
he pays it off three years later in 2013
okay with interest at the time he has 6
000 employees he takes it from 6 000
employees to 100 000 employees do you
think that 464 million dollars that he
got from the government that he
borrowed if that was given to somebody
in the government to do you think
they're going to get that kind of return
and produce
94 000 jobs of people in the free market
that taxpayers don't have to pay for so
patrick let me ask him please who gave
him the 464 taxpayers did okay so the
government did so you just made an
argument for the government being
awesome at this
because they gave it to elon musk the
government made the decision to give it
to elon musk and it turned out to be a
great investment but it's
congratulations government but i agree
no what i'm saying is i agree versus
when we see some of this money when they
say we're going to do 5.8 trillion
dollars where's the money going to okay
so now let's break it down okay so
uh the government sometimes gives out
subsidies uh that make a lot of sense so
for example when they give to renewable
energies fox news went crazy about
cylinder because that was a that was a
company that lost money but when you
looked at the overall portfolio that was
a thing that obama did really really
well the overall portfolio made tons of
money and gave it back to the government
so that was a success story and so fox
news eventually dropped solyndra because
it was embarrassing because that
government program totally worked on the
other hand some government programs or
actually most government programs are
just built to be robberies okay so
people think oh the people on the left
love the government no it depends what's
the government doing is it invading iraq
then i hate it right is it saying hey
women can't control their bodies then i
hate it it's big government tyrannical
jack-booted thugs coming in telling me
what my wife can do or my daughter can
do [ __ ] off for my life government okay
so what is it what is what's the
government doing so a lot of the
subsidies are just robberies so when you
right now we still give billions of
subsidies to oil companies why they're
the most profitable companies in the
world why are we giving them subsidies
those from a hundred years ago when it
made sense
now they don't make any sense at all and
no one thinks they make sense they just
do like mansion
constant subsidies to coal why he owns a
coal company mage is one of the most
corrupt people in congress
so but they're all corrupt you you name
it or you talk about hunter biden orton
hatch's son was a lobbyist who just rode
off his dad right so whatever he wanted
pass he'd go tell his dad and his dad oh
technically we didn't meet at all it was
somebody else for my son's company
lobbying company and they would pay the
sun millions of dollars and then orrin
hatch would pass whatever the hell they
wanted so this robbery's been going on
for a long long time so it depends on
what you mean by government yeah i agree
with that where some of the money goes
in places but we don't get the return
but you give a money to a guy like this
who's doing well who brings and makes
money for you and he pays 11 billion
dollars in taxes this year that he's
actually selling some of his stocks
because that's an event that's a tax
event yeah should we not celebrate a guy
like that no when he pays his taxes i
celebrate okay
and and you know the government forced
him to do that so he wasn't going to pay
his taxes you know it was the structure
of that particular i don't know if the
government forced him no it was so
patrick that that particular yeah so
there's two different things that happen
in that one it was the type of stock
grant that he had it was coming due and
he had to pay taxes not he wasn't
choosing to sell at that point but but
he did choose to sell a lot more which i
think was him saying tesla's probably at
its peak let me take some money off the
table while pretending but you see that
you see what happens here then then
here's what happens at this point so
what happens what you just did is
there's no way this guy can ever win
with guys like you never no that's not
true but wait a minute but what you just
speculated and you that's a speculation
first part okay fine i get it like
they're forcing to pay taxes but you're
saying now he's paying more oh it's
probably because he thinks tesla's at
his best so regardless this is he cannot
win no no patrick i'll take it i don't
care why he's doing anything i don't
care politician if they're the greatest
should we applaud this guy
so again it depends what are we
applauding him for yeah so patrick in
your example by the way he gets 464
million from the government yep
why didn't the government take equity
think about it if somebody we're all
business people right whose fault is
that okay hold on so if
somebody's gonna give me 464 million
dollars yeah they're going to take a lot
of equity they're going to take 99 of
that equity right that's how the markets
work but when the government do does it
they're like oh we got paid back that's
not investing that's not investing why
don't we get equity so you mentioned a
aig we bailed that aig one hundred
percent of course absolutely and
thirteen million dollars of that was a
backdoor bailout to goldman sachs again
that 13 billion dollars was nothing but
a robbery a goldman sachs took chances
in the market they failed at those
chances they should have been punished
by the market for failing instead the
taxpayers bail them out because of the
goddamn corrupt politicians mainly
republicans but yes a giant portion were
democrats and obama helped in that
robbery let's keep it real now you say
when i say that msnbc loses its mind no
the beloved obama and the beloved biden
and pelosi are perfectly clean get the
[ __ ] out of here so mitch mcconnell
raised a billion dollars so does nancy
pelosi when
mitch mcconnell raised the billion i was
like can you believe this corruption the
koch industries giving money to mitch
mcconnell when pelosi raises the billion
dollars they're like she's an angel
no
they're both bribes our politicians get
bribed on the regular so that those
subsidies to elon musk and a lot of the
renewable energies turned out good for
the country so overall i say i'll take
it but the correct way to structure that
is significant equity for the american
people and then sell off by the way but
by the way i don't disagree like let me
give you an idea no on the one part i
don't disagree okay so the first guy i
raised money with for my insurance
company i said uh he says i'll give you
a few million dollars okay great equity
or debt purely debt and it was a
revenue-backed funding debt which i
don't know you know if you know how that
works it's a very
it's a taxing loan that it's a taxing
money you're raising right so ends up
being 33 you're paying per year yeah i
mean so you know how that works right
but you're a startup and you're like
yeah you know okay i'll take it i need
the money we paid him off a year and a
half later the second guy comes around
he says i want to give you 10 million
dollars i said 10 million and at this
point i want debt i don't want equity
yeah he says i don't want that i want
equity of course well that 10 million
dollar guy paid him 40 million dollars
so he's sitting pretty saying [ __ ] can i
get some more so he calls me two weeks
ago he says can i give you another 20
million dollars because i said no no i'm
good at this point we're going to be
totally fine so i get that part that's
the government lack of ability to
negotiate the right contracts for tax
people which you should have asked for
equity in tesla it would have been
better for everybody else can you
imagine how much the government would
have made if we got equity what a great
return to the government ever do that
though actually get equity in these
private businesses they can for example
i think when the banks all crashed they
should have nationalized them in the
short term then gotten equity and then
sold them back into the private market
you don't want the government running
all the private banks that's crazy but
when they go bankrupt you still need the
financial system to function
but when you rescue them as any investor
that rescues a business would have
nearly 100 of it right so you get so the
american people get it so when when they
get back on their feet and they get to
profitable we at least benefit from that
instead what the american people do is
constantly just give away billions of
dollars to corporations and get nothing
in return why because those corporations
gave millions of dollars in campaign
contributions to those corrupt senators
and and uh representatives yeah so
they're just getting free money because
they're being bribed i i i support the
fact that elon didn't give up equity
good form because he doesn't want to be
controlled by them that is a choice that
the individual can make sure whether you
want to do that or not the last thing
you want is every time i go to dmv they
treat me like [ __ ] every time i go to a
different institution that's not run by
the government they treat me better when
i was in the army and i was in the army
for a few years it wasn't like hi mr
david how are you i was like hey
specialist stand over there like okay i
mean that's just not how things work in
free enterprise he doesn't have to take
the money that's right that's the same
he made the right money you always give
the tsa versus clear analogy dude clear
treats you royally hey mr david how are
you how's your day tsa can you stand
over there please sir ma'am i don't care
stand here let me see it it's a very
very so to the the government ran
organizations typically
when you travel do you fly clear where
do you go
pre-check what do you do i do tsa
pre-check i love it i i think it's
perfectly good enough i know other
people unclear love it even more i i
hear you i like both i just want to be
given a little bit of a better service
by a government organization and you
don't get that by government
organizations they treat you like they
own you but it's a very different energy
that you get yeah i hear you on that too
and sometimes you need private and
sometimes you need public right we can't
there's some things like cops military
that we have to have public that's why
the word socialism doesn't make any
sense every economy in the world is a
mixed economy every single one of them
sweden's a mixed economy we're a mixed
economy
uh and so some of it is public it should
be public we used to have private fire
departments in america it was a disaster
because every house would burn down oh
he doesn't have insurance we're not
going to put out the fire
oops there goes a whole block right some
things need to be public including
health insurance so there just needs to
be a perfect balance and mixture there
needs to be a mixture because life is
about balance so saying the government
is bad doesn't make any sense seeing the
government is good doesn't make any
sense the question is what are they
doing and how effectively are they
carrying out that mission yeah you get
some people that say taxes need to be
zero well you can't do that i'm a public
school guy so where would i have gone
would i have my parents who don't have
money what would have been my
opportunity military i feel the budget
that we have in the military some say
well we shouldn't have that big of a
budget for military well that's because
you feel safe and you forgot what war
felt like maybe you've never been
through war and know what it is to be a
weak military where everybody attacks
you kind of pays to be a badass that
nobody wants to attack you but when that
happens the people that are raised in
that environment become too uh uh
ungrateful and they're like no we're
spending too much money now do i think
the current strategy of where the money
is being spent in the military is wise
while the other guys are investing into
cyber and bio and we're investing in
traditional ways of fighting 40 years
ago i don't know i'm not in there to see
the budget i don't know where that's
going to i just don't know if that level
of innovation is happening with the
military funding speaking of taxes i
think you had this exact debate with ben
shapiro i remember you're saying i don't
think taxes should be zero but i also
don't think it should be 100 he was
debating on like yeah
in the reagan days it was ninety-one
percent that's something
what's that what's your number your
what's the number you're saying so
patrick uh i used to be a republican and
so my dad left it started his dirt poor
southeastern turkey uh all a farmer
the reason part of the reason i'm
progressive today is because in turkey
back in the 1960s they had free college
education to anyone who could score at
the top okay so my dad and my uncle
worked their ass off to score at the top
of the of those college entrance exams
and without any money they got into the
he got in the best engineering school in
turkey then he set up his own company i
mean he is the american dream and i
interviewed him and conservatives loved
him right and they're like how did a
jackass like you come out of that guy
right
and so and i'll and it will go even
further my dad was basically chased out
of turkey by communists so he had set up
a business and they were threatening his
life because he was a capitalist pig
okay now still we're progressive because
we have none of this if the government
did not provide a free college education
to my dad right now i'd be an olive
farmer in southeastern turkey a lot of
the right wings going ah
yeah
bro yeah
so
um now having said that though um
why did i leave the republican party
because every part of it turned out to
be marketing so like you talk about the
defense con
budget right do we need a strong
military of course we need a strong
military uh and so you can't have no
military it's nuts right but um
but do we need this level of monstrous
spending with no accountability where
they waste billion after billion because
it's not wasted it's going in the pocket
of defense contractor executives so the
correct answer is balance so that brings
us to taxes so
when they had it at 91 percent
right
then we were republicans and and
reagan came in it was still at 70
percent
our family is still republicans right
nobody paid 91 by the way at the time
just so you know yeah and that was you
say that but nobody ever paid 91 there
were so many loopholes the average guy
was paying 40 to 50 percent who was
making money because they so even though
i get what you're saying the 40 years of
taxes there's nobody that was paying 91
at that time yeah and people have to
understand that that's above a certain
number and the number is super high
the famous story with reagan was that he
would make a hundred grand for each
movie and then after 200 grand as the
time is in the 40s or whatever it was
anything over 200 grand it's a 91 he's
like i'm not doing a third freaking
movie yeah i make 9 on the movie so he
would just do two movies a year and that
was basically impetus for his tax plan
yeah so so there
is a point where taxes are too high
right
but right now we've lowered taxes 128
times i'm making that number up it's
hyperbole but but probably if you look
at the real number might be right around
that or more
we're constantly lowering taxes on rich
and most importantly corporations right
so and then they remember when they're
in the trump tax cut they were gonna do
two trillion dollars mainly for
corporations
what happened mr populist uh and then
they were supposed to take away the
loopholes what'd they do instead they
did two trillion dollars in taxes they
didn't take away a single loophole they
were lying all the time republicans were
lying democrats were lying none of them
took away a single goddamn loophole so
it was a two trillion dollar giveaway uh
to the richest people in the country and
to corporations so taxes should be
around
it should be layered right progressive
like reagan uh so late well progressive
taxes is american like we've had
progressive taxation in america where
would you put the top line
you know above a billion dollars uh it
would it would be a it'd be a high
number i mean 50 at least above a
billion dollars in earnings or earnings
in earnings yeah earned income
you're not talking capital gains capital
gains i'd put it whatever is the normal
tax i think it's outrageous capital
gains is low okay yeah so okay so
interesting so there's a few things that
you know you just said that uh uh
uh uh i actually you know like when you
say corporations you know i can't
believe we you know we had the
corporation taxes because our
corporation tax were the lowest it was
the highest at 35 points nobody paid
that to your point you're right nobody
paid it but it was high because they
just kind of let the money flow and they
took it out by debt or dividends or in
different ways that they can avoid
paying that
35 percent and then i think trump
brought it down to 21 21 and then it's
back up to 25 they're going to move it
up by the way
so that's exactly how they good got
packed up of republicans democrats
republicans bring it down from 35 to 21
biden comes and goes i'm going to bring
it back to 28. wait it wasn't at 28. it
was a 35. mainstream media doesn't say a
word about it right then manchester says
i don't want 28 i want 25 and then biden
says i am the bold leader who's going to
get it to you at 25. wait a minute you
guys just took 10 points off the
corporate tax rate
by biden did that under the obama
administration by the way bush passed
massive tax cuts for the rich but they
couldn't make him permanent because it
was so unpopular then obama gets into
office has biden negotiate with mitch
mcconnell he makes 94 percent of the tax
cuts for the rich permanent
the democrats did that not the
republicans it was binding himself it
was such a terrible deal that other
conservative democrats were livid
they're like how could you give
mcconnell 94 of what he wanted by that's
why i say biden is conservative biden
will give republicans anything they want
24 7. they have too many stuff on biden
if you ask me but here's the other part
you know how every time they're like
let's
send money to you know to people to help
them out and bail them out every time
they print the money and send money to
them what are your thoughts on sending
money to people hey here's a thousand
dollars here
a week stimulus checks what's what what
are your thoughts on so every andrew
yank model even a ubi i would assume you
would support some like no okay so um
so
it all depends on context it all depends
on the facts so
when we were in the middle of covid did
people need to relief checks yes
so i supported that completely um
ubi has some issues including they take
away a lot of social services to be able
to do ubi and i don't love that concept
and
and so i you know and and progressives
are split about ubi there's a lot of
different thoughts on it and i'm sure
there's good progressives who love it
and would disagree with me but i think
just giving money is not the most
productive way of the government
handling you know why do you know why i
don't think
uh you know how they they did a case
study with ubi i think in alaska i don't
know if you've seen that study or not
when they did in alaska and they started
sending money like ah this didn't work
alaska still does it for people that
live there because who wants to live you
know so
when guys were in fort wayne wright my
friends were in the middle you know
what's the great thing about living in
alaska every year the state sends me two
thousand dollars i said yeah when you
ets are you staying on alaska hell no
that's why they pay you 2 000 right
because you don't want to live there now
some people will argue that if you like
that lifestyle more power to you the one
area that uh if if you were to look at
the current uh
system that we have we typically ask
this one question i'm curious to know
what your answer is going to be guy
asked me this question yes i'm like you
know no one's ever asked me to question
that i've asked others i asked joe rogan
this question out of the five
uh uh organizations and individuals i'll
give you tell me who's got the most
power president of the united states
virtual governments which is you know
facebook youtube twitter all those guys
we call them virtual government and then
you got the educational system you got
mainstream media or you got the
billionaires in order of top five who
would you put as the most powerful not
least powerful one one more time
president
virtual government
educational system mainstream media
billionaires
so it's
i think it's relatively easy
billionaires have the most power by an
order of magnitude
way way way more the president has the
least power by an order of magnitude
because politicians are basically
servants
uh they their waiters and waitresses
that the mainstream media does marketing
for uh they take an order hey uh donor
would like this and they execute the
order okay i would pass a bill in favor
of the donors so why did for example why
did ted cruz turn around on a dime i'm
gonna get trump i can't believe he said
that about my wife and i'm gonna get him
and he said that about my dad and he's a
dishonorable man and then he's like i'm
gonna phone bank for donald trump i love
donald trump please re-elect donald
trump okay hey he's true story by the
way 100 true a he's a [ __ ] okay uh but
b let me explain to you why he's a [ __ ]
because when he gave the speech at the
convention and did not endorse trump he
then went up to his daddy which is
robert mercer that's his donor that gave
him 13 million dollars look again we're
businessman patrick somebody gives you
13 million dollars they expect something
in return okay especially in politics in
business they expect a return in
politics what do they expect they still
expect their return
but through corruption okay so when when
he goes up to the turn on investment
exactly when he goes up to the suite of
the mercers robert and rebecca they
slammed a door in his face they got a
new boy it's donald trump and ted cruz
miscalculated because he lost his donor
that's why he was like oh i'm sorry
you saw my wife all you like i know i
never really she's not that pretty
anyway
right she's ugly donald trump what do
you need me to do okay
because he is that's who they are they
so the president barely has any power
when when the donors tell uh biden
you're not gonna pass the fifteen dollar
minimum wage shut up and do as you're
told biden says yes sir absolutely sir i
can prove it i forced the vote the young
turks did a petition that forced bernie
to introduce 15 minimum wage in the
corona virus relief bill they had it in
there originally they took it out and
they were never going to vote on it why
because it was going to be embarrassing
to the democrats then bernie does do the
vote he did the right thing wonderful
okay guess what it was just republicans
eight democrats voted against it
including the two delaware senators
the two delaware senators are not voting
without checking with biden there is top
allies that is biden saying i didn't
mean it i was lying the whole time i'm
against 15 minute wage the whole time
pretending that he's in favor of it if
you watch mainstream media they tell you
joe biden's in favor of the 15 minimum
wage no it was a lie so mainstream media
second most powerful on that list
but they're also servants the
the wealthy are at the top corporations
are at the top everyone else serves them
okay the educational system
that's had that is a variety so because
it has a history right and sometimes
exactly sometimes it's wonderful like in
the 1950s and 60s education in new york
was the best in the world and it
produced uh
amazing businessmen entertainers you
name it right so they
when i was growing up we had great
public schools i went to a public school
in new jersey right now it's an absolute
disaster in places like california why
because they lowered the tax base and
they privatize the schools and they
funnel the money to private schools and
they starve the public schools so the
educational system is important because
that's where we teach culture
now the right wing would agree with me
that we teach culture there but we
disagree on what we should teach so you
put education three
uh i i think education three uh
presidents five so who what's left what
was the digital media virtual goal oh no
my bad virgil government is is uh
now now you're thinking about no no no
no no they're number three
yeah but they're almost at number two so
you got billionaires at the top yeah
then you got legacy media number two
then and then virtual go government's
digital media number three that's right
educational system number four and at
the bottom of the totem pole the
president united states definitely so
here's how i have it okay
uh
i have president at the bottom just like
you do i don't think president is you
got eight years what are you gonna be
doing and quite frankly eight years you
gotta have congress on your side center
there's a lot of moving parts for you to
be able to do a lot of things done and
they're funding you from the back so
you're working for you guys agree uh
that part i agree absolutely at the at
the second to the lowest i put
mainstream media because mainstream
media is a byproduct of the money guys
meaning
mainstream media is nobody without the
funders which is billionaires
billionaires make mainstream yeah
whatever you're talking about so i put
mainstream media at fourth i put uh
billionaires at third i put educational
system at second because it's got a long
lifespan kind of like what you were
talking about so if one side of the
political party gets the educational
system you got them for decades so if
you got for every one conservative
professor 12 are you know on the liberal
side
you got a monopoly there that's a
full-on monopoly so that's problematic
because you're able to indoctrinate
younger generation coming up that's a
lot of power that's number two and i put
number one at virtual government because
i think those guys are becoming just as
powerful as the government if not bigger
uh you know they can do a lot of
different things they can have a lot of
control over other things and you have
to go through them they're not going
away so you can do a lot of things you
want to do but you kind of have to go
through them the virtual governments but
you put billionaires at the top the one
area lobbyists let's talk about
lobbyists so
which
i i think you love lobbyists they're
your best friends right you're a big fan
of lobbyists they're your favorite like
we should have gotten a shirt for you
saying i love lobbyists right
so so if you think about do you think
trump and bernie like lobbyists do you
think they like lobbyists uh no my guess
is they probably well no no no no let me
amend let me amen so uh you're kidding i
despise lobbyists of course i'm kidding
right yeah and so bernie probably
despises lobbyists just as much but
there's a bud in there because there's
public interest lobbyists that he
probably will meet with right yeah and
so now if for trump
he says he dislikes lobbyists but if
they come with cash they're his best
friend he'll love him right away you
know trump he'll say what am i gonna do
say no they have money for me i'm going
to say yes
why wouldn't i take their money he said
about the saudis he said it about the
russians yeah of course lobbyists are
you kidding me
he's like what do you need let's make a
deal okay you want me to give you a
trillion dollars you give me a billion i
give you a trillion at least i have a
billion let's make a deal i don't know
about that by the way jake your trump
impression is a little mafia new york
underwater there's a reason for that oh
wow i got a little bernie in there you
know i was like wait is that bernie yeah
so that's hang on bernie trump bernie's
net worth is three million dollars okay
he's been in government for what 40
years all he's written a book but you
don't make three million dollars you
actually do
i this book is not that good hold on
tyler are you saying 3 million is a lot
or a little uh for a government employee
unless you're doing what nancy pelosi is
doing and you're an inside trader i
think it's
far more than your net worth should be
for 40 years ago for 80 years old you
think three million dollars is a lot i
think it's very little
so whatever you're doing yeah so look
for the average american three million
is a ton of money right so i hear if
you're young but if you for an average
politician that's almost nothing yeah
right i don't think there is a lot so to
your point about nancy pelosi she's
gotten spectacularly rich she's worth
she's 100 million she beats the she
beats the market every time there's a
index fund that tracks nancy pelosi's
bets because she just because it's
obvious insider trading right and the
difference is she's a crook and he's not
right so he made most of the money from
books from what i understand there is
you can't there's believe me if i
thought anybody on my side was corrupt i
call him out immediately i got no
tolerance for that at all so patrick
though you see what i'm saying about
trump likes people with money lobbyists
have money so
are you saying trump would say oh i
don't want a deal no no no i'm not i'm
not saying that but i want to come back
to this one guy that asked the question
about the which we'll come back to you
in a minute but i'm not saying that what
i am saying is the following um if you
look at the people that have been
assassinated historically okay
it's been who you let's just say the
ones that we know about let's say uh uh
jfk okay he wanted to get away with
federal reserve and he wanted to pull
out a war he wanted to he even lyndon
johnson didn't like the fact that this
guy didn't there's a lot of things they
did not like the direction jfk was doing
but he couldn't be
controlled because he had money reagan
he made his money was he a billionaire
no but breaking had money it's not like
he was struggling for money he had a
nice place in santa barbara he had you
know whatever the number was they
couldn't control him ah maybe we got to
do something with this guy now don't get
me wrong i've read the tip o'neill book
i've read the books on reagan on the
other side where he was a deal maker and
he would say we got to make deals happen
we got to give him some to get some
great he was still a good deal maker
you go to reagan you go to lincoln i
think and you said character
assassination versus the other side i
don't think trump is a guy that you can
buy
uh uh because he came in with money he
funded his own campaign so if you sit
there and you say but but think about it
who funded his campaign so who funded
his campaign how much money did he spend
on his campaign patrick you could buy
trump for like five bucks trump will put
sell anything including his soul any
policy position he he wouldn't there's
anything you wouldn't sell nobody and
patrick but there are facts on on how he
funded the campaign in the beginning he
put some of his own money in the minute
that he actually got funders she's like
get my money out of there put the donor
money in and she's got your supplement
as well in 2020 she was almost all donor
money not almost all all was the order
money okay so he and then what did he do
he raised 200 million for a legal
defense and hasn't defended anyone he
hasn't defended the january six guys he
hasn't defended rudy giuliani his top
guy isn't defending anybody he's just
hoarding the money and he put it in
there hey suckers by the way i can keep
all this money okay i don't have to
spend it on legal defense and what does
he do in his campaigns he started
charging three times five times as much
for rent in his own properties and said
that he was renting it out for the
campaign and there's no campaign office
the guy's a long i mean
you can flip it and say that bernie
wasn't paying his own workers 15 bucks
an hour yet he's screaming off the top
of his lungs to do 15 bucks an hour so
now they the same criticism can be on
both sides i would agree yeah so the
same criticisms can be given on both
sides but what i'm saying about the
lobbyist side
if if i had it my way i think they are
probably the biggest problem makers in
america today i think they're holding a
lot of people back with a lot 100 left
right middle i don't care and you ask i
ask a lot of people saying will this
business model ever go away and say
that's not going to go away why is this
business model not going to go away
because congressmen are making 170
whatever they just got a 22 raise i
don't know what the number say they're
making 200 grand a year and then they're
retiring and then you got a lobbyist job
making a million 2 million 5 million 10
million euro why would you give up that
opportunity to get away with it right i
had one of my uh uh
agents literary agents for my book that
he published he was a former lobbyist i
said tell me how ugly this is pat as
ugly as you think it is
it's a hundred times out there i said
get out of here says no i'm telling you
it's very ugly he says he says i made
money but i couldn't wait to get out of
it i don't want to stay in it because it
was a very very ugly business model what
do they mean by ugly like how old when
you say ugly define that so you know
what a lobby what does a lobbyist do
yeah they buy politicians basically so
how do you buy them how creative can you
be as creative as you want right okay so
what what does creative mean though go
get creative what things do you have to
do what motives do you have to find what
drives people how do you you know
there's so many ugly things i don't even
want to get into like you know you
remember the story with cartagena what
happened i don't know if you remember
that story that was 12 13 years ago
where congressmen were in cartagena
partying and a different story there but
lobbyists um just open-ended question to
you what needs to happen
for the system to get rid of lobbies to
not even allow for lobbyists so
boy yes right guys so i started a pack
called wolf pack wolf dash
wolfdashpack.com to get all money out of
politics okay be so how we're going to
do that you have to end the private
financing of elections if you finance
elections through a private system the
politicians will always work for the
people who sign their checks that's just
capitalism 101 that's logic 101 okay if
you do public financing of elections
then they have to work for the public
now people go oh my god that's we're
paying the goddamn politicians to run
for office yes either we're paying them
or soros is paying them koch industries
is paying them then they work for soros
or coke if we pay them then at least we
got a fighter's chance of them working
for us and on top of that you make
penalties for if you're getting private
financing you're getting money funneled
to your either your campaign or your
pocketbook we're going to put you in
jail
we're not going to have corruption in
american government you're going to
serve the american people and not the
people the industries that are buying
you so you said soros i tell
conservatives all the time come join
wolfpack it's totally nonpartisan we
want to do election reform you want to
do election reform we want to do a live
stream report we want a constitutional
convention it's actually technically not
a constant it's a convention
that is put together to amend the
constitution
conservatives should love that
progressives love that the establishment
hates that because it's real change we
get the money out and then people say oh
yeah would you take sources money out of
course i would why would i say oh yeah
yeah take the coke money on the mercer
money up but keep thesaurus money and by
the way source of massive capitalists
right of course yeah and so he's
socially liberal but economically he's
still conservative as well so no but it
doesn't matter even if he agreed with my
hundred percent i'd still take his money
out because i don't want the politicians
being bribed so that's how you get at it
the lobbyists will exist but if they
cannot influence your election and they
cannot influence your money then they
have a lot less power you still have to
close the revolving door the one you
mentioned at the end when they retire
they get the big checks
and that's the hardest thing to do
because when you tell politicians you're
not allowed to make millions after you
retire they're going to fight you tooth
and nail
to the end
to the end yeah do you agree with him by
the way who uh which part i mean you're
talking about campaign finance reform at
the end of the day right here and yeah i
mean you're no fan of lobbyists i know
you can't you kind of give them an
open-ended question
but so you're saying if you're running
for office use your own money to run for
office no i'm saying public financing so
you can't take anybody else's money okay
so otherwise you were worried you're
going to work for them so you go and the
way that it works and you use your own
money uh in most public financing
systems yes okay so it creates a
loophole for the rich and some
progressives don't like that that's a
different issue but the great majority
will be just normal people five bucks
ten bucks twenty bucks fifty you have to
qualify and the way to qualify is to get
a certain number of signatures depends
on where you live in your district and
your state you get a certain amount of
signatures and you have to get a certain
amount of money raised but usually it's
like five bucks or ten bucks at a time
so you're actually raising money from
real people it's one thing to do a
signature at the mall it's another thing
to give somebody five bucks a big
difference yeah this is what you're
talking about with bernie his famous
singles the oldest thing the average
voter gave me 18 of the individual
donations did you follow the michael
porter and catherine gill when they came
out with the book the industry of
politics and they're trying to change
the voting system did you follow any of
that or no not specifically okay so it's
a similar uh they're going a similar
direction but a question for you who by
the way if you go with that format that
you're talking about
who would win who would that benefit and
who would be against it so say you go to
format that i get to use my own money
or public money to run for office
you're saying that because you think
that would benefit bernie because bernie
would get the most public money
no i'm saying that first of all i've
been saying that for 20 years well
before the rising benefit though
well before grassroots fundraising was
even a thing um so it would benefit the
people because and now then it gets to
the question of
do i think the american people are
fundamentally progressive
or is it a center-right country as the
media has told us our whole lives now if
you're a conservative and you think the
country is mainly conservative you would
love that system i'm a progressive and i
think the country is two-thirds
progressive so i love that system so so
so that makes sense because if i were to
ask
my kids what percentage of them would
like me to make their bet instead of
them making the bets it's two-thirds
probably three-fourths
so so do you understand what i just said
right i don't know what i just said
right so i believe if the if the
individual is not protected
and somebody comes in saying if you vote
me and i'm gonna give you xyz
i do believe that's majority the country
is going to vote for an easier life than
a harder life where you have to carry
the weight and you know
pull your own little red wagon or as jfk
would say you know don't ask but you
know
what your country can do for you what
you're getting for your country but uh
yeah it's interesting to see that would
benefit uh but by the way patrick you
know you just made an argument against
democracy
tell me tell me tell me why because
you're saying well if we let people vote
with for their own interest they're
going to vote for their own interest
yeah that's called democracy yeah so
then the question is
what is the right balance
okay because that's always the the
balance that you have to strike because
like let's say the people voted for hey
you know what i want the government to
give me uh to give us each a million
dollars right well the government's
gonna run out of money instantly right
and then all of a sudden they're not
gonna have any social services nobody's
gonna pick up the garbage why because we
already gave you a million dollars then
they're gonna go oh okay we overdid it
sorry sorry sorry let's course correct
now that's an extreme example obviously
right and you would never get to that
point but you would get to a point where
you would tip the scales into the wrong
balance from time to time but the idea
that we should not serve the people
because then they will want things is
absurd that's the whole point of the
government is to serve the people the
things that they want like security
police military etc right healthcare so
they can stay alive
and and other things and then we all
decide hey do we want that or don't we
want that at what cost do we want it
instead the system we have now is the
very very rich decide what they want so
and they get the media to lie on their
behalf about what they want i get it so
what i would say is i would flip it on
you and i would say i'm okay
with
that side
as long as we add an element of you
having to earn the right to vote which
you're not going to like this but
earning of course you're not going to
like that part because
to me if i'm living in a household and
my kid wants to tell me
what color i should paint the wall and
he's 18 years old not paying rent yet
you have no right to tell me how to
paint the wall or do anything if you
contribute to society no problem if
you're paying taxes no problem if you've
earned the right to get a job or get a
degree or serve the military no problem
minus the one percent who have don't
have the ability they're disabled they
have health challenges like that i think
everybody else needs to contribute to
society to do that i
you know the structure patrick hold on
let me just say two things about that
one again
just
definitionally you're gonna go back to
democracy you're and i'm gonna say
republic where the individual has to be
so you're against democracy right so
let's just be clear i'm universally
involved i'm for the following i came to
america feeling i need to
do more for america and that america
needs to america doesn't owe me [ __ ]
i owe america
no i'm sorry what do you mean it depends
so america didn't america didn't tell me
to come here i chose to come to america
i owe america everything not the other
way around no so patrick i came to
america too and i love america and um uh
i'm sure we love a different america but
yeah well apparently but i'm optimistic
i love this country i think we're going
to get back on the right track i think
we're in dark times now but we're going
to get there and this country gave me a
lot of opportunity gave my family a ton
of opportunity it's so it's got but it's
an agreement right so but it's okay to
say one of the reasons we came here is
because it's a democracy and we get to
have
a say we get to have a vote that's part
of the reason we love america you're
right and you've got to earn the vote no
you don't because patrick think about it
okay i think you said you were poor we
were poor when we were growing up right
very much poor would be an understanding
yes or would be rich to us that's right
yeah and so what did the government do
it gave you a set of opportunities it
gave you a public school and for my dad
it gave up all the way up to college but
for us high school right it gave us
roads and bridges too and i'm introduced
to it and i'm indebted you're indebted
to the united states government
okay good great i appreciate that i
appreciate that but that's my government
i'm here now you can't say hey welcome
thank you here's the thing the the dream
that we sold you but now the rich run
the country so [ __ ] what would i say
that's not what i said no no but wait a
minute you came to america and you've in
your own way contributed you said you
got 70 employees right that's 70 people
that are not relying on the government
for an income they're getting it from
you and young turks and you've got 30
part-timers patrick it's always balanced
because they also get a lot of things
from the government they also get police
protection fire department schools
all those things from the government but
i'm not disputing that up yeah kidding
me of course you know if you and i were
to start a country right now we go and
say hey uh we got 10 million
square miles or whatever we got 10
million
we got a good sized land say south
dakota's ours now and we want to attract
people nuclear war took place we're
running this place what's the first
thing a mom's going to ask before they
move to our country security safety of
course so she's going to want military
she's going to want police she's going
to want fire department moms are going
to decide what state and country they're
going to feel safest to put their kids
to right yep and that's where they're
going to go i fully support that the
fact that you're you're offering that to
me right america's offering that to me
but i'm indebted
to america for offering that to me
meaning i have to give back not i have
to take but but patrick do you think
that when you and i were poor we
shouldn't have been able to vote
we had not contributed as a what at what
age of course 18 i think a voting should
be i think to me voting is not age
you're going to think this is crazy when
i tell you this i would much rather have
a 15 year old kid vote
who has paid 5 000 in taxes because he's
got a job than a 24 year old vote who's
never had a job yeah that's what i think
to me it's not an age thing to me it's a
contribute contribution to society thing
but if the poor can't vote then they can
never get policies that help the poor to
become middle class or rich but i'm
sorry but the poor can't find a way to
contribute if i'm poor i don't have
anything i joined the military that's my
way of contributing i work at
haagen-dazs at 15 years old and i'm
paying taxes that's the only way i can
contribute i don't have a lot of money
i'm poor my mom's living there with my
sister now my dad's having heart attacks
left and right he's making 1500 bucks a
month at uh 99 central in in westwood
then he moves to inglewood right by
great western form which you know that
entire area i don't i don't but that's
why that's how i gave it so i i think
the challenge a lot of times with the
argument is
that hey come here we're going to take
care of you no no no no
come here and contribute to young turks
come here and contribute to this
environment that we have and we in
return have to give you good 401k
benefits so we have to give you good
health benefits we like to come like i
know i know you like to say companies
are not individuals or companies are not
countries but if let's just say people
are working and i don't give you
benefits
somebody else does i'm not competitive
but if you come in here you're not
providing value to the organization
you're always late you have a bad
attitude you're complaining you're
bitching all the time you're recruiting
people to be complainers you're probably
not going to stay here for too long yeah
so we have to realize who we're turning
into heroes for me
even an individual who has had a job
who's cleaning whether it's waste
management whether it's whatever it is
you're doing but you're figuring out a
way to contribute to society and taking
care of your family patrick i salute you
but patrick we agree on that a hundred
percent we our families worked our way
up so which part of it is no challenge
so all of that is wonderful
i'm just saying
yes
but if you're poor or you don't happen
to have a job now and i'll give you a
specific example that doesn't mean you
shouldn't be able to vote that you're
taking away universal suffrage that's
that's not what i'm saying so so like
for example mo and my dad i'll give my
caveat but go ahead yeah when my dad is
going to college
he can't work at the same time he's
barely able to survive right and that
college is super hard at the time right
now i think college is way easier these
days anyways so at that time technically
he's not contributing to society but
what's he doing he's turning from an
olive farmer to a mechanical engineer
and a businessman right so in that time
he needs a little bit of a hand up and
not a hand out like there's an old
clinton line it's true how long though
yeah that's the question and by the way
patrick will some people abuse that of
course it's human nature right and you
put in safeguards you put in guardrails
but it doesn't mean you take it away i
think you said your family used food
stamps or something like that of course
yeah see that and so that was the
government helping you when you really
really needed
but i'm flipping on you for how long
though
for how long you should just be that's
just a balancing act so if you say hey
you know what i think it should be three
years and then you got to be
self-sufficient that's what i'm saying
and i say five years or the other guy
says one year okay we're having a debate
that's okay that's nothing wrong and
then we don't have a child like for
example like unemployment you got five
of course you need unemployment to go
find a job what are we talking about
here but put a timeline to it not 24
months not i actually agree with you and
that's where some progressives don't
agree with me but i i i i will i'm on
your side on that how like look it
happened to me when i was in florida we
were working down at whammy and down in
south beach uh and it was barry diller's
tv organization
he sells it to univision we're all
unemployed it's hard trying to get a job
as a tv writer especially in florida so
i go on unemployment
did i did i go on unemployment the
entire time and milk the whole thing of
course i did that's what everybody does
right what are you gonna do turn down
the unemployment check so uh but at the
same time i don't think everybody does i
don't i don't think everybody does and
but but by the way you've contributed
you've contributed so to me
i i you've created 70 jobs
that it's almost like this people ask me
a question they say
how do you feel about your
brother-in-law see y'all mac okay
i say what do you mean how do i feel
about this comment you say something to
see on mac you're gonna have to deal
with me this guy's my family why
because a bro i'm a younger brother by
six years five years and ten months let
me pull it off camera also she's only
older than me by two years because if
you look at it you'll think i'm the
older one anyways
but she's older than me five years 10
months right but i've always been the
older brother and a little bit protected
my parents got a divorce i kind of have
to be that you know i understand what
the motives are with men i know it
myself i know what they're trying to do
so i got a little bit protected
she marry seal mac
best wedding ever i think it's november
23rd or something like that or three we
go to the wedding ridiculous wedding
incredible wedding oh two or one or one
of those years anyways
he starts taking care of my my sister
do you know when's the last time i was
concerned about my sister's health
protection
safety finances do you know when's the
last time i went to sleep worried about
that
two years before they started a day
before they started dating
okay do you get what i'm saying
so the moment these guys are together
i'm like dude this guy's i call him a
saint is what i call him he's an
incredible father to his daughter he's
an incredible father to his son i salute
this guy when he came together he says i
just want to tell you man i love you we
had a moment i'm like dude you got to
tell me you love me bro i love you we
got emotional was like telling you
you've you've made my life easier i owe
you you contributed to this family right
what can i do for you to me everything's
about earning and and i think we have
missed the definitions of freeloaders we
got an elizabeth warren calling and elon
musk who created a hundred thousand job
freeloaders and millions of people are
agreeing with that and we're forgetting
that freeloaders come in different
facets you know they're coming from
people that don't want to contribute my
only challenge with what you're saying
is
if you contribute great
you've contributed created 70 jobs great
i don't care what side you are
politically i just care that you created
70 jobs because you made taxes lower for
me and my hat's off to you do you
understand what i mean by my tax is
lower for me that's that's all i'm
saying with this part of it but
by the way who would you not take money
from you've raised money i don't know
what if you go to crunch base you know
26 27 million bucks you've raised some
money from certain people you see
katzenberg you'll see this you'll see
that some guys that have given you money
who would you not take money from yeah
well uh
i've already done that practically in
many many instances so i'll give you
some examples sure first of all in terms
of advertisers um when we were current
tv chevron wanted to advertise and we
said no
so
we think the fossil fuels are destroying
the planet and we don't want uh them to
be a direct advertiser okay so
for-profit colleges i think they're a
scam we said no so we say no to
advertisers all the time we now focus on
uh on the ads that we can control the
direct advertising uh we focus on
progressive companies that are what are
called in the good economy like
aspiration is a great example of it
their financial institution
you would love it they create tons and
tons of jobs uh they've got an
interesting uh niche in the market and
and they're transformation and they're
trying to make money by doing good in
the world but they're still making money
right and they're still a company so
there are those great companies that i'm
happy to support and there's many that i
would reject in terms of investors
for me we had a lot of trouble raising
money
because our competitors have raised
billions like vice has raised i think
nearly 2 billion
vox raised 200 in their million in their
last round buzzfeed 400 million in their
last round before they went public so we
raised 20 million in our last round all
in all we've raised 25 throughout the
entire history of the company we've
actually paid back a lot of that money
so i now control the company completely
editorially
managerially and financially in every
way right so i'm super happy that we
we've got complete control and but that
was really hard patrick because a lot of
people
investors they don't in the vc world in
the private equity world it doesn't work
like in right-wing media in right-wing
media a fracking
magnet comes and says i will give you
funding to start your company but you're
gonna have to be pro fracking that's
just obvious okay in the vc world in
private equity world they don't care
about your politics at all they just
care about the bottom line how quickly
can you grow how quickly can you get
them the money back what's the you know
if it's debt how what's the interest
rate if it's equity how much equity what
are the rights associated with it so
people the reason we had trouble is
because i'm a pain in the ass i'm a
stubborn guy and so do you want to
change
no not at all well that's kind of the
definition of stuff yeah but
but there's an irony there because i
i've changed a lot of my positions
throughout my life i told you earlier i
was a republican right so i i now can't
stand republican but i don't think it's
position like that i don't think that's
the position i think sometimes
the entrepreneur you i are difficult to
deal with which naturally that's an
entrepreneur spirit because you're like
hey you know but but the one thing i had
to learn the hard way bro very hard way
because i'm also you know extreme i'm my
dad's son and my mom's a son so if you
meet both of them you'll realize it's
like double whammy from both sides that
i got right so middle easterns are not
really so but but i had to learn i have
to sit there and say okay all right this
makes sense why the concern you would
have with this okay this makes sense
okay like for example i'll give you one
thing i had a call on my board
and my board had a call and it was about
vaccines okay and hey what are we going
to do to increase the vaccinations of
our sales officers because you got to go
on why don't we offer it to them why
don't we have somebody go and fund it
and spend the money i'm like
okay um
so it was a three-hour board call
strictly on this because there was
breakouts and when there's breakouts you
gotta have these calls we don't want
anybody to have any kind of health
issues so
we had these calls and we went through
it i said okay i'm gonna think openly
and just keep poking me and push me and
challenge me and see if that have a leak
in my argument and so that's what we did
so i said this and they said this well
citigroup was doing this well i'm not
citigroup well those guys are doing this
well
i said listen man we started the company
with the cause being to save in america
i said this in july 17th of 2009 dressed
like george washington my wife was
dressed as lady liberty at jw marriott
palm desert we had a 40-foot mount
rushmore on stage and i'm saying saving
america by bringing back the free
enterprise system and hope to american
families like my whole premise is
freedom you want me to force these guys
to do this to go there
i don't i don't know if if it fits the
vision if it fits the cause if it fits
who we've attracted all this time but
what i'm willing to do
i'm willing to make people feel
comfortable because a lot of people were
feeling uncomfortable
about if i get vaccinated am i part of
that community if i don't give up a
partisan it became so political that if
you've got to actually people almost
didn't want to save their accent or not
so i did a video and i sent it out to
everybody and i said guys this is the
video i'm going to do and i told the
board and i said very reasonable do it
so i shot the video i sent it to
everybody so this and i said look guys
here's where it is
there's a few different camps with
vaccines there's a camp that
has it and doesn't give a [ __ ] if you
care whether they got it or not and
they'll publicly advertise it and they
think everybody should get vaccinated
there's a camp that doesn't want to get
vaccinated because they think this is a
conspiracy theory and they don't think
they need it unless if you're xyz you
shouldn't get it kids okay that's that's
that camp right they knew what my
position was and where i stood i told
everybody my position i said but there's
a camp in the middle that you feel
guilty because you're going to
disappoint somebody here's my suggestion
to you let me speak to you and then i
spoke to that camp because that camp was
having a hard time making a decision on
which way to go and the board said fair
you allowed some people to come and
openly come out and say hey i got the
vaccine good hey after the research doc
i'm not great but we took that approach
i had to learn that as a seal and a
founder and it was very very hard to
allow that feedback to be given but i
think the other part is also the vision
like what's the vision of young turks
how big you want to build it how big you
want to scale it maybe you're not vox
maybe you're not vice maybe you don't
want to go that angle maybe you know
because what what makes it very
complicated for guys like you shapiro
uh glenn beck you know is you're also
talent
which is tough right i mean if you're
also it's a lot of pressure on you
that a lot of people don't realize
because you know you have a talent
you're like i want to try to recruit
this guy but [ __ ] i just said this on
aaron oh
it's it's very complex with the position
you got so i can understand the the the
complexities of where you're currently
at yeah well honestly a lot of
executives are
are
more in the establishment democrat camp
to be honest okay and so
when they see me on air and i'm ripping
biden and i'm ripping pelosi etc
they get uncomfortable
and so they're like i don't know that i
could you know do that sure yeah yeah
and so so that's just realities of it
that means we just have to work harder
so
look in business i believe in win wins
you win lose is short-term win-win is
long-term you can get to win win but you
just have to work harder to get to win
if you got a 10 million your offer right
now from msnbc for three years would you
take it absolutely not you wouldn't take
it no foxy i already turned down msnbc
and offered me over a million uh back
when i had made no money i had i was had
no money you were gonna be a contributor
you were not gonna have you were you
were not gonna be 6 p.m you were going
to be on the weekends i think right yeah
so i had 6 p.m they want to move me out
of 6 p.m even though i had the highest
ratings they ever had at 6 00 p.m into
the weekends yeah uh and my point wasn't
hey you're moving me down my point was
why right because i said phil who's
running it at the time phil griffin and
i said if my ratings are the highest
you've ever gotten is the rating's a
problem he said no of course not i said
am i a bad guy internally am i causing
trouble and there's no no everybody
likes you okay so what would get me back
from the weekends to prime time is what
i asked and that was the most awkward
minute of silence you've ever seen in
your life because the real answer was
stop criticizing democrats
and he can't say that to me
so he just fumbled around and basically
said at the end do you want it or don't
you thinking
nobody ever says no to cable news nobody
ever says no to that kind of money right
and and so i said no i don't want it um
and i did my own thing and and so to
your point patrick about entrepreneurs
we're stubborn for a reason because we
have a vision we have a certain vision
for what to do so if you tell me i gotta
apply a set formula
that doesn't make any sense for my
company for my business
because you learned that in business
school or you applied that to every
company that you went to important it's
not like you went to work for management
it's not like you went to a community
college right no i'm not going to do
your set formula i'm going to use my own
judgment and i'm going to execute my
vision i just i just learned long-term
humility helped me out and being too
cocky and arrogant hurts when it's the
business if you're the talent no one
gives a [ __ ]
you know like for example have you seen
the movie the late shift with the
uh the story of letterman and leno you
ever seen that movie no i didn't see it
i think you would highly enjoy it if
you've read the book i've read the book
and i've watched the movie it's a
90-minute movie no i should watch it
you're right i think you would really
enjoy it if you watch it but you know
like
i have guys that i want to recruit and i
want to put them on talent
and i'm saying i'm like mad i'd love to
have you on but
some of the [ __ ] you say is gonna get
you a strike on youtube it's just going
to get you strike on youtube so you know
what i'm going to be a little bit
patient and i'm going to create a
platform that a guy like you i can
recruit you and i can pay you but i'm
going to put you on an ott
and you can make money revenue
membership all of that but you can say
whatever the hell you want because the
bylaws are no longer what it's no longer
a youtube or a facebook or this but if
today youtube you say one thing this
that vaccination next thing you know
they're taking the whole thing down they
did that with a few different channels
you got they took about 80 of our videos
down the last two years 80 of our videos
they took that last two years so you
have until we have our own youtube until
we have our own ott until we have our
own thing you got to play by different
rules let's talk about the joe rogan um
joe uh euron joe i want to say 13 or 14
i don't know what it was it was when you
guys run it was fantastic by the way
when thank you um i yeah it was a while
back yeah 6 7 and by the way it there
was a lot of admiration both sides when
you guys were talking because he was
like you know the the coming up and that
was before he was getting the 11 million
an episode a week or whatever it was and
you were like king kong you know when
you guys sat down together but you made
a comment you said you know joe
something i'd kick his ass again i'm
taking it out of context
of course i'm assuming you were just
kidding you were upset about what he
said can you unpack that exchange
yeah comments you made about rogan yeah
so
i like joe a lot and and uh we even
grabbed lunch we were friendly i was
thinking of uh
i even pitched him to be a host on a
show we'd pitch to cable or networks etc
okay
and yeah and uh
and and i like joe's independent
attitude a ton right or what used to be
an independent attitude right uh
nowadays uh i think he's lost his way so
i think uh he got captured by the right
wing he doesn't even realize it almost
all his guests are right wing or fake
left wingers who are pushing for
right-wing agenda and so
and that's he surrounded himself with a
wall of right wingers and he's created a
bubble bill maher is the same way
a wall of right wingers they're all
they're all their friends are right wing
right and so now he's not independent he
doesn't do both sides he doesn't have
real you think he's a right wing yeah of
course you think joe's right yeah i do
yeah and so is he right of where though
no do i think he's right right off
center or right of you no right of
center okay but but broken okay so r2
you're saying again it depends on the
issues so you can take an issue that
bill maher is super liberal on and go
come on you can't call him right wing
right but i could show you ten issues
where he's just obsessed with cancer
culture and only from the left-wing
perspective not the right-wing
perspective
he loves by the way bill maher loves
corporate democrats okay just loves him
to pieces so uh so to me
on economic issues he's
same issues as all those corporate
democrats anyways so so joe
it's a matter of emphasis so i hear that
he's pro-choice but does he ever talk
about that
almost never right
uh but on any right-wing issues oh my
god trans rights this that the other
thing he's like super animated about
right whenever it's a right-wing issue
he will spend hours and hours and hours
discussing it if he has left-wing
positions
not a peep
there's a thing called audience capture
where your audience starts to go in a
certain direction it starts to build
momentum then if you try to change all
of a sudden your audience numbers drop
and people panic okay now joe's already
rich so he doesn't have to worry too
much about that i think he got more
guest guests captured than audio's
captured but like guys like jimmy dore
get audience captured like crazy so once
they like jimmy dore used to be on the
left and he was doing comedian right he
was in our network one of the worst
mistakes i've ever made and uh in
southern
yeah okay and so he goes independent now
he uh he's at one point he's doing
pro-vaccine videos he got a vaccine
they're not doing that well right then
he does one that's vaccine skeptical it
does great
okay so all right then he does another
one that's vaccine skeptical because he
wants the views he wants the money right
and so all of a sudden that's then next
you know he's done 20 videos against
vaccines or vaccine skepticism because
that's where the audience is going
that's where the money is going and
that's how and there was a progressive
in our network who said look the same
thing happened to me i was criticizing
democrats so much from a left-wing
position but i was criticizing democrats
and one day i woke up and i found out my
audience is right wing like i asked him
a poll question holy cow these guys are
like 70 right wing so he's like i had to
make a principal choice there and i did
and i cut off 70 of my audience and i
started talking more about my left-wing
positions not just anti-democrat
positions right so that's what happens
so on rogan to your actual phys the
specific question
so
now i have animosity with rogan but yeah
i was largely trolling them like it's
and i said it very clearly too never in
the streets never any violence violence
is crazy but i was saying if you want to
step in the ring
uh i mean obviously you know what would
happen if you stepped on the rink you're
not no
so would joe have a massive advantage
obviously look at me i'm 52 i'm not i'm
very overweight etcetera but by the way
i don't think it would be a foregone
conclusion i'm oh you think you could
take joe okay now you're saying
one kick and decide you'd be peeing
blood for a
week he's seen his kicks like yeah i've
seen his kicks okay so i appreciate your
confidence though i got to tell you no
but i'll tell you why i do okay so look
number one
i'm okay a trained person is of course
better and by a lot right so and a guy
who's in shape as opposed to a guy not
in shape buy a lot so i would do tons of
training etc and i'd still be a massive
underdog okay but i'm a brawler and and
so it's not just that i fought my whole
life when i was growing up et cetera
it's the will in you right so if he's
going to beat me he's going to have to
beat me he will beat you yeah and that's
fair yeah and that's a fair conclusion
to reach okay but my point is i
i'm tired of people running over the
left wing okay so i if you're gonna say
we're weak
then [ __ ] off and step in the ring okay
so step in the ring ideologically that
is what i would greatly prefer by the
way i did this with michael smirkownish
a long time ago on a huff post right
he's talking [ __ ] about oh the
wussification of america and i was like
all right [ __ ] then either get in the
ring from a debate point of view or or
get in the octagon or whatever you want
right because you're saying we're
wussies and i'm saying i'll kick the
[ __ ] out of you okay so you tell me you
know what what michael summer connors
did he ran like a [ __ ]
okay and he went and cried to mommy and
he said oh my god he's threatening me no
no i said look in you know
i would never do it in the streets
that's nuts okay i'm 100 against
violence but you're not going to call us
weak and get away with it we're going to
stand a god damn post and that's why the
young turks are hated by the right wing
because we do not back down we punch
back so the whole point there patrick is
rhetorical i'm punching back retort yeah
but you i and and by the way that that
was how i took it yes but that's not how
the world took it i mean i'm sure you
know that there's a part of that was
marketing i get that but let me let me
go through a couple of these but i like
triggering the right wing i like to be
oh no wait man we're tougher we're
tougher really i don't think so i don't
think if anybody by the way alex jones
who raided my set right i stood up yeah
and all of a sudden he wasn't so [ __ ]
tough anymore right
so all these fake tough guys on the
right wing joe is not a fate of kaito
bro i get what you're saying i get what
you're saying but but uh you know uh uh
in in regards to him being right wing
like that is uh the guy said he would
vote for bernie sanders yeah now you
guys have found conor ground yeah he did
right and i so that was like the last
semblance of him being independent since
then he's gone completely another
direction 100 percent in another
direction and by the way he supported
trump trump's a lunatic so i mean you
can't see what do you mean you supported
trump he he said that he
look if i'm wrong i'm happy to retract
it but my understanding was he said he
doesn't like either option but between
trump and biden he preferred trump oh
okay no i think the way no i think the
way he said it
i think the way he said it is he he
thinks trump uh had a stronger way of
dealing with things than biden does i
don't think he said i would vote for
trump over biden because he could
clarify by the way why doesn't he
clarify that's such an easy thing i
think he's like like hucker won't say
whether he took the vaccine why don't
you just say it what's wrong with you
right yeah so who'd you vote for what's
the big deal i mean you do a show that's
got politics all over it yeah why would
you be afraid to say who you voted for
and if i remember what jimmy said man
somebody said it here as well vanessa
aponte but by the way jimmy all of a
sudden started showing up and you know
he he he had an adverse reaction to the
vaccine or something happened with yeah
he didn't have any adverse reaction so
he's trying to make money he's a total
con so so here's a few things
so let's let's go through uh uh some of
the superchat and if we can get callers
in if you want to get people to call in
we're going to go to a few callers here
because people want to talk to jank uh
we have uh okay so chris armageddon
general rules
draw okay the young turks says okay so
freddie says the young turks is the new
msnbc
uh
robert brake says we have a system
that works for most people the problem
is largely education and to some extent
healthcare capitalism isn't a problem to
solve people are not moving themselves
beyond entry-level jobs is a big problem
great point by robert blake
uh uh so you disagree with that look
these days it is so hard to move up
people say oh yeah go go to burger king
get a 8.25 job and then magically work
your way up yes you can but it's not
magic what do we need we need to the
resources to be able to so here guys
give you a quick sense this is based on
race but it gives you a sense whether
poor white uh poor bla or or rich right
so
uh the average uh
wealth for a white family is 10 times
that of a black family it doesn't mean a
black family can't make it and i agree
with you patrick hey
uh industrious work hard believe in
education etc and and so do almost all
black leaders they all say the same
thing but is it harder when we know from
personal experience is it harder to get
up
when you have one tenth of money of
course it is it's like start doing a
hundred yard race and somebody's
starting at the 80 yard line you're
starting at the zero yard line yeah
maybe i could win but that's going to be
tough that's going to be tough so
constantly yelling at people at the
bottom of the economic ladder is not the
right way to do it encouraging them in
positive ways giving them the right
incentive structure that's the right way
to yeah but but but at the same time the
guy that makes it with nothing
is a hundred times tougher than the guy
that was handed stuff out okay the guy
that makes it from nothing's gonna be
that's why i'm 100
100 times tougher than trump
[Laughter]
here's another one that we got uh
patrick christopher chapman patrick what
about a basic civic test to show you
understand how the country government
works but i would love to understand
what's going on no see okay in reality i
wouldn't do it because it those tests
then get rigged that's exactly what jim
crow was but are you kidding me if we
did a civil uh uh
test uh it to vote we'd eliminate 90 of
republicans they don't know what's in
the constitution at all i mean the
politicians don't know the voters don't
know they don't know anything about
america i don't think it's the same on
the left also though i look so when you
do polling you you see that both sides
have issues like for example bill maher
as mad as i get adam uh did make a good
point the other day you always have to
listen you always have to be open-minded
and he said now like democrats think
there's a if you get coveted there's a
50 chance you're gonna die that's crazy
yeah that's nice that's not true at all
right it's about it used to be about
like one to two percent and that was
dangerously high now it's way lower than
that so you have to
you have to actually do facts science
etc right so uh so it just uh
depends on the circumstances i keep
going back to that because i need people
to use their minds so can democrats be
wrong from time to time because they
were watching
of msnbc they can of course they can but
on average the republicans get factual
things
massively wrong these days
so the things they like the election was
stolen just not true not remotely true
right now every right wingers go no i
read it on jim jablowski.com on facebook
no he lost 60 cases in a row he never
presented a single piece of evidence
all conservative judges all trump
appointed judges said you did not
present one piece of evidence of fraud
so he lost 60 cases in a row because
there is no evidence all those
republican legislators in the swing
states said there was no fraud because
there was no fraud it's a giant giant
lie and forty percent of the country has
lost its mind did you ever did you ever
on young turks talk about that
uh uh
trump was a russian spy in the russian
store did you ever yourself talk so
somebody
russia yes okay so let me explain what
so i did what is
it i always have a unique position
because i'm not in the camps right i
look at the situations and the facts
sure so
the democrats said oh it was because of
russia the dollar trump won i said no
that's not true hillary clinton lost the
election and we
you know that's to say that she didn't
lose the election is conspiratorial just
like saying trump won the election in
2020 right so and she made a thousand
excuses [ __ ] you ran as an
establishment candidate and you lost
because the country is in a populist
mood and by the way you're also an idiot
and you should be forever humiliated for
that loss so
the the russians did not
rig the election with trump how like
there's basic facts so
uh roger stone who i despise is probably
the guy i hate the most in politics
went and tried to get
information from wikileaks
about what the russians were up to well
if they were coordinating with the
russians why did roger stone have to get
information from wikileaks so they were
obviously not coordinating with the
russians why did they have to do a
meeting in trump tower with the russians
if they were already working with the
russians so
they were not working together in the
election having said that did the
russians help trump well that's a fact
that's obvious they got the dnc emails
by the way they might have also gotten
the republican emails but they only
leaked the democratic emails and those
emails were greatly damaging okay so did
the russians help yes did they
coordinate no
does trump
want to work with the russians
definitely how do i know that based on
what trump has said and his sons have
said so his sons have said on several
occasions we get all of our money from
the russians yeah okay well i didn't say
they said it yeah you know trump he's
obsessed with money and you know that
they bought a russian oligarch spoke
like a third of trump tower when trump
was in trouble what was that we all know
that was money laundering we all know
that was money laundering
russian oligarchs aren't buying a third
of a tower in the middle of manhattan
because uh they they need more property
like oh they need to live there or
that's the vacation though they're
cleaning their money and trump says i'll
take it what am i gonna do right but if
you but if somebody who's got all the
time in their hands to go back and look
at your record of your videos and pull
up and say what you said about russia
would somebody be able to make the
greatest hits of all the times you said
you know he's a russian spy he's linked
to russia he's this would they be able
to put creative greatest hits patrick
people are doing that about every single
issue
right you know the only reason i'm
asking this is the following here's the
owners and i'm asking this okay
you know he himself he
trump's story you know wherever whatever
position he's got with trump he can
speak on his behalf but when the durham
story came i was like what the hell like
you know this is all we heard you know
there's a lot of people that they ran
with the story without having all the
information and they backed it up
there's a lot of things we don't yet
know and we're not going to learn for
another five ten years a lot of stories
takes a long time for it to come back
and reveal itself all i'm saying is this
is the only thing i say
when people say stuff about you okay
let's just say they say
here's what's going to happen with
chance i called around i've seen you i
know you're like so how is this guy he
says you're going to love him you guys
going to be good you're going to have a
great conversation but then he's going
to leave and he's going to talk [ __ ]
about you i'm like what he says that's
his style i said okay
i don't know that i've never dealt with
you that's what they said so far you've
been here uh it's chill i'm actually
enjoying the conversation we're going 17
minutes over where our podcast how many
podcasts have we gone over 11 o'clock no
we're over 17 i'm actually enjoying this
conversation right so somebody says that
about you all right next thing i know
you go and you do a podcast next week
and you're trashing me then they're
right okay so that's the part where
sometimes in media you know what you see
and who you talk to is different than
what they leave and they talk about you
i think that's where a lot of
so patrick those people are totally full
of [ __ ] and i can prove it in every
instance so for example um
right now you guys have said nothing
that i haven't challenged to your face
right and so whatever i've said i've
already said there's nothing else to say
okay so we have a debate with ben
shapiro for example right i said my
piece he said his piece what do what
does he do his he already had it planned
out you know you could say it's good
business okay but he immediately takes
totally out of context clips
and chops it up and puts it all over the
internet okay fine no problem okay then
i respond when i respond they cry
oh young jerk so i can't believe they
took parts liberty wait [ __ ] you just
did that a minute ago i'm responding
every time i respond to someone people
go on rogan's show lie about me 24 7 24
7. it's like a little cottage industry
why by the way the algorithm is rewarded
since young turks has been the largest
online show for a long long time if you
attack us
then the algorithm goes okay let me
serve up videos next to the young turks
videos and they ride our dick basically
they ride off of our
uh oh saying shapiro rides your dick in
the beginning he did for sure crowder oh
my god he used to dress up as me he
would go around town dressed up as me i
mean it doesn't get any more riding a
dick than that okay
and i don't see shapiro as one of those
so he's happily married he's got kids no
no
no no it's just a saying i don't mean it
that way
so
okay so are you saying if someone
punches you punch
punch back 10 times harder it's so
that's what you're saying that's exactly
right so you and trump have something in
common that's exactly right no no by the
way that is right yeah so what i'm
trying to teach progressive politicians
is
look don't go around picking fights for
no reason for theatrics to make yourself
feel better to vent etc
but pick fights for a purpose or answer
fights for a person my dad is the most
peaceful guy you'll ever meet i don't
know why he told me this but he told me
when i was growing up he said never
punch anyone first but if someone
punches you punch him back so hard they
never punch you again and i would when i
was a kid i would literally let the
other guy take the first punch and it's
the most unnerving thing they're like
you just are gonna let me punch you in
the face yeah i am go for it see how it
turns out you literally did this i
literally used to do that yes okay so
i i don't punch first but i punch back
so [ __ ] hard they cry for year after
year after year
so so why don't we do if we have some
colors let's get a few colors and then
we'll wrap this up uh you know what i
love the most here's what i love the
most i love a good debate i love a good
exchange i love the fact that audience
wins what our format is right after this
we're gonna do
uh how many short clips are we gonna do
five seven eight we'll have shoulders
okay and they go on vtsc and they're
three to eight minute short clips uh
that'll go on there and it'll drive back
to the interview but if you got callers
let's get a few callers john's got a job
just john sometimes he only takes
callers from ladies but john let's see
who you got here today uh we have
roberto okay good roberto how are you
i'm doing great i have a question uh
patrick love the show love the civil
discourse here
so my question is to both you and to um
jenk
i'd love both of you to answer this
why does it feel like um the left pushes
a specific narrative that america has
rampant and overwhelming poverty when
the data that we have even from the
government says otherwise it's horrible
that we have poverty but it is less than
14
of the country so over 80 percent of
people not in poverty sounds like a
pretty good thing
um the median income is 55 000 a year
you can live on that in most places of
america 65 of american adults are
homeowners less than 1 million homeless
less than a quarter million unsheltered
so why is are we being convinced of a
narrative
that americans are destitute when we
could talk about improving it why is the
narrative from the left that everybody
is poor when that's clearly not what the
data says yeah so
that's not the narrative but it is a
failure of the left that it has left you
with that impression so when you talk
about income inequality that doesn't
mean everybody is poor what it means is
there's something wrong in the system
that instead of everyone having the same
rights and the same opportunities the
system's been rigged in favor of some
what rights don't people have in america
so for example when an oil company uh
and there's a lot of different issues
here right but i'll try to give you some
examples so when an oil company gets 14
billion dollars in subsidies well
roberto did you get 14 billion dollars
in subsidies
jank i didn't provide services to
millions of people in america or provide
services they're making a profit
you're not entitled to equality they're
not entitled to it either
they what services they provide services
we pay them we pay them a lot of money
class american issue
so what i'm trying to tell you roberto
is that if we took if we distributed the
government money more equitably it would
not go the majority of it would not go
to the people who are already
spectacularly wealthy it would be more
fairly distributed and that is what you
should root for not because hey we just
want to give money to the poor because
we want a government that actually
functions and gives equality of
opportunity not results equality of
opportunity and i keep going back to the
example of my dad getting the college
education for free because that's
opportunity nowadays you don't have that
opportunity and and roberto like i've
had people on the show and you see it
back in the day you could buy a house in
la for there's a guy in manhattan beach
who bought it fifteen thousand dollars
in the 1960s now all those houses cost a
couple of million dollars at a minimum
everything costs more now college cost
three times exactly because the
government decided to back student loans
without capping the interest rates with
the banks which they should have
negotiated you i think agree with the
student loan debt crisis everything is
more expensive i can't buy anything for
the price it was in the 1950s and people
in the 1950s couldn't buy it for the
price in 1920s that argument makes very
little sense and not everyone lives in
california anyone can actually with a
working-class salary get into a home in
north carolina or georgia or anywhere in
middle america as a starter home for
about fifteen thousand because they
don't need twenty percent down they can
do a five percent down yes it's higher
so you guys have a sense that the left
thinks you shouldn't work and that
drives me nuts
when did i say that no that's it's
overall this idea of like hey uh we're
making it seem like uh the the country's
impoverished and we need to give all the
money to the ports that's not what we're
saying all we're looking for is equality
of opportunity so if you say hey the
government
if you say the government hold on
roberto if you say the government didn't
do the right interest rate on student
loans okay great but i think the
government should uh provide free
college so you all have opportunity but
at the end afterwards not necessarily
give you money like universal basic
income etc earn your way but set up a
fair system so it isn't emphasizing the
poor or saying america's poor in fact we
say this all the time on the show
america is the richest country in the
world and then we say we can't afford
health care for our citizens every other
developed nation has
universal health care they don't let
people die we let people die
then when you're dead you have no
opportunity right so how how do we do
that if we're the richest nation in the
world obviously we have enough money
we're just choosing not to prioritize
the average american we're choosing to
prioritize the richest people and the
biggest corporations roberto uh what are
you based out of just curious how we
lost them oh we lost them okay
roberto if if you're listening on the
podcast uh text john back would love to
stay in contact with you uh but
appreciate you for your question jen
thank you for taking that question let's
go to the next card
before we get to the next caller
breaking news jenn saki is leaving the
white house uh for msnbc of course if
you want to address that
yeah
it's all one giant circle you know pull
it up on the news okay so
uh so they hired these government it's a
revolving door so hey uh
now she's gonna get paid millions by
msnbc guess what she's gonna say she's
gonna say that establishment democrats
are awesome and she's gonna say trump
sucks and she's gonna say bernie sucks
and she's gonna do she's just gonna go
and she's now she did marketing for the
government now she's gonna do marketing
for corporations so it's the same thing
it's the same but i think it's funny the
timing part of it that it happens right
after hunter biden's story was on wapon
two days later this happens to you uh
talk about timing when jedediah got
fired a week after she asked a tough
question from hillary clinton you know
what i'm talking about jedidiah bill i
think we had her on a few months back
view that was a timing thing this is a
little bit of too much of timing do you
think it has to actually deal with that
i'm just purely speculating i don't have
any information i'm speculating do we
have another color let's do two more
callers and then we'll wrap up john yes
we have ryan okay ryan how you doing
hey good thanks so much um
thank you so much you guys for doing
this seriously like this is this is like
amazing what you guys are doing talking
together so
i um
i'll kind of preface this with saying um
hello yeah we can hear you go ahead
what's your question okay go for it so
um
thank you so much for you guys for
seriously doing this talk like this is
this is so amazing so um i'll kind of
preface my question with um
you know i i grew up with a dad who came
from iran and like you know he's an
entrepreneur and everything
and he really like
i'm fortunate enough to have a dad that
really pushes me to succeed in
everything like he had a very similar
kind of upbringing that you guys did and
i respect both of you guys i have to say
i'm getting a little bit more towards
the conservative side but like i watch
both your shows and what you guys are
doing is great but
my question is like you know i'm seeing
a lot of people
in my generation like
and i obviously i didn't live in in your
generation or any generations before
that but i feel like it seriously seems
to me that people are getting a little
bit lazier
and uh you know like less willing to
work like
regardless of whatever narrative either
side like so go ahead
yeah no i could address that so
it depends so
why because the we just talked about
this on the show the other day the the
president of blackrock came out and said
something similar hey this is the first
time that anybody's uh
can't get whatever they want because the
entire generation is experiencing what
it is to run out of stuff yeah exactly
yeah well that is true but it's only
true for the entitled class
his kids because he's a billionaire has
have always had whatever they want but
now you have supply chain issues and all
of a sudden they can't offer their uh
order their next lamborghini and they're
crying to daddy so are they entitled of
course they are but it's not just them
the the rich and to some degree the
upper middle class
their kids are super entitled these days
i mean they'll come into a company and
they'll be like what it's been three
weeks why aren't i the ceo
i don't get it right but for poor and
middle class millennials in gen z
they're not at all entitled they're
having to bust their ass they got
student debt everywhere they can't
afford housing they're they can't afford
health care they're hurt and they're
trying to work their way out of it and
that's the the silent majority of
millennials in gen z you never see in
media
excellent thank you for that okay do we
want to go to the next caller yeah we
have cameron on the line go for it
cameron
yes sir how you doing
hey i'm all right i'm at work right now
let me hop in the truck fantastic what
do you do by the way
um i do internal french drains so
waterproof basements fantastic so tell
us what's on your mind
sorry just ran over to the truck um hey
[ __ ] dude this is a great podcast um i
don't agree with you on like anything
but
sorry i'm not impressed god bless that's
america brother
hey [ __ ] you've been great on this
interview man you've been really good
uh patrick david
you're a star um dude
i make so i live in pittsburgh i make
eighteen dollars an hour and
i move around three thousand pounds a
day
um i actually would just moved up from
15 an hour um
thankfully i'm
i was making the uh quote-unquote
minimum wage so my question was uh
excuse me my question was uh
how could you um as a small employer
i have like nine thousand dollars in the
bank right now as a small employer how
would you pay your employees
um because i think the argument of
15 minimum wage is a little disingenuous
whenever um
it's just a little disingenuous whenever
the government doesn't control the
market prices if the government
controlled market prices i think it'd
make a little more sense but yeah thanks
guys
yeah so look there there's a legit
question about um what do you do with
small businesses
if the minimum wage is 15 an hour in
kentucky right and so i think that you
could
um
do carve outs for example if you're
having under 50 employees you're still a
small business and maybe that's a
different situation so you have to be
really thoughtful about how you balance
those interests right but overall we
have got to get to 15 i mean
i think his name was patrick he'll know
because that's the way she used to get
until recent camera camera oh camera
sorry
that's my transfer
so cameron brother you know 15 an hour
is about thirty one thousand dollars a
year that isn't a lot of money at all
you could barely live on thirty one
thousand anywhere right we california
sure that's impossible right new york
it's impossible but kentucky it's hard
on thirty one thirteen thousand should
we throw a kid in the mix yeah of course
of course so we have got to get try to
get people to that bare minimum right
now the actual federal minimum wage is
7.25
and you think oh nobody gets paid that
that's not true a lot of people get paid
that and you know what that gets you
that gets you fifteen thousand dollars a
year that's poverty below the poverty
line yeah that is how the hell are you
supposed to live on that whatever if
you're 16 it's your first job you know
but look
that's such a misnomer i hear you that
does that happen of course it happens
right but is that the average minimum
wage worker no
40 of women make under 15 an hour 47
percent of blacks make under 15 an hour
so this is a giant portion of our
economy and we have got to get them to a
living wage and by the way cameron and
almost all the callers they're saying
hey this is a really interesting
conversation
and and they didn't know this about me
like they were having this
conversation and they didn't know the
full context of my thoughts
why do you think that is that's because
of what patrick mentioned before and the
the right wing will take and now the
fake left wing will take videos of me
totally out of context and they'll make
it seem that i'm someone that i'm not at
all and then they'll ascribe positions i
don't even have to me and then they'll
make up positions so that's why when i
go on rogan's podcast when i come here
and we have a full conversation people
go holy sh i didn't know that that guy's
actually fighting corruption tooth and
nail i've been fighting corruption the
entire time i've been in media and
politics i've been fighting the corrupt
democratic party the entire time that
i'm they hate me way more than the right
wing hates me right but you've got to be
honest and principled you've got to have
actual principles and apply them to the
facts at hand
yeah so for me uh when you said 40 women
47 blacks african-american under 15
bucks an hour
my uh uh focus would be to
increase the skill set in the
marketplace i dictate my value in the
marketplace when i first came in the
marketplace i had nothing to offer i
went to get a job after the military i
was a hummer mechanic and i was a
marksman as a shooter i wasn't even like
the best one but i was a marksman i go
on my resume and i go to a gym like so
what are some of your expertise i'm a
phenomenal hummer mechanic hv
and i can shoot somebody from 300 you
know
so we don't have a need for that it's
magnets or you know
but i'm telling you i'm a ridiculous
mechanic no one gives a [ __ ] okay like
improve your skill set so i had to pivot
and get better and i put a lot of time
in the books but cameron the question
you're asking my encouragement to you
would be to find collaborations when
you're smaller great partnerships matter
great collaborations matter savings
matter with your nine thousand dollars
and uh increase your skill set but find
other guys that are in your position
that you can have the right partnerships
with to help increase your valuation
anyways let's do let's do the last one
while he's doing this let's do last one
last caller and tell john and we'll wrap
up go ahead just just to finish the
thought camera to i agree with patrick
and you always there's different levers
right so if you can't afford it does
your i know it's a small company but
does it have equity can you instead of
wages can you do equity can you find a
different way can you find a reasonable
loan but don't get in over your skis
just find the right balance that works
for you
last one johnny tell us who you got john
we have darius darius how you doing
darius
i am grateful this morning how are you
i'm grateful as well tell me what's on
your mind what question do you have for
jen
all right so my question is
it's a two-part question but
with right now trust in mainstream media
is continuously decreasing and our
political divide among citizens is
continuously increasing so my question
is
do you think it's important for
journalists and political commentators
to be examples of objectivity when
covering people and issues
yes so that's a great question uh number
one mainstream media did this sleight of
hand that's really important they
replace objectivity with neutrality
wait those are those things are totally
different right uh objective is uh the
lakers now my second part to that
question is if you agree that that's
important how would you rate yourself on
your media company and what you put out
how would you rate yourself in terms of
the pursuit of objectivity on a scale of
one to ten
so
to
to finish the point brother uh so
objective for straight reporting is the
right standard not neutral okay you
don't say both sides are equal well it
depends are they equal or aren't they
equal right you have to be objective
about the facts so on in our reporting
when we talk about any story on the
facts we are 100 objective we never ever
play with the facts then we give our
perspective so that's like a newspaper
you get the the facts in the front and
then you get the editorial in the back
right so we do we have a perspective yes
and we're honest about it our
perspective is progressive and
everybody's clear about it mainstream
media also has a perspective it's that
corporate rule is awesome status quo is
terrific nothing should ever change and
we should stay at the top and you should
stay at the bottom but they're not
honest about their perspective and then
they take their corporate perspective
and call it objective objective my ass
there is so zero to ten objective young
turks
on the facts ten on the facts ten yes
and then on our perspective that's up to
you do you really
okay you put yourself as a tent
absolutely okay no no there's two lines
that are networked yeah one is
never advocate for violence right uh
obvious exception of mma etc that's
that's within a ring within prescribed
rules right but never advocate for
violence and never play with the facts
crazy complete different question for
you here
uh but do you think the washington
redskins being forced to change their
names was the right move
so that one's tricky too so because now
you have that name that's
over the top offensive there is no other
meaning for
uh that word other than to be derisive
right then you've got the indians and
you say well their mascot's terrible but
the name itself is not necessarily
offensive then you've got the chiefs a
perfectly acceptable name there's
nothing wrong with this seminoles is
actually
an ode to the particular tribe in the
area that's actually good it's almost
complementary so in the case of
washington it had no other meaning at
all it was obviously derisive
uh and there so i would say yes change
it in that case so changing it to
commanders
whatever it is it is a commander's
command
no clue so let me ask you this so
to to an armenian the young turks may be
offensive would you change your name
yeah so young turks means young rebels
that's the colloquial use in the english
language you could actually look it up
in the dictionary and for us it was
young progressives challenging the
established system i mean that is a
textbook definition of what we are quite
literally but i get that it is offensive
to armenian people i get that and so
uh and i and i feel terrible about that
especially because i was wrong about the
armenian genocide so when you talked
about that yeah respect for the fact
that you did that yeah i think anna
asked you the question and you addressed
it yeah yeah and so i say her name right
anna right yeah yeah uh so when i was
growing up i grew up with honestly
turkish propaganda right and so we all
get propaganda you guys talk about the
education system you know what is it
telling people yeah i remember they
taught this absurd thing that i didn't
realize i was absurd because i was kid
right they said turks had never lost the
war except world war one and world war
one was a little hard to deny right so
but i believe that and i remember as a
grown up i remember reading about how
the ottomans had lost the battle and i
was like no no the turks never
oh my god i can't believe i believe that
all these years because they implanted
it in my head right and of course that's
not true the church have lost tons of
battles and wars right and one of the
things i was taught was that the
genocide didn't happen well of course it
happened serbia is considered a genocide
and 8 000 people died there right in the
armenian genocide
way more than that a lot more than that
died and they didn't target norwegians
they targeted armenia so was it based on
uh
that ethnicity race clearly it was and
and they were targeted so
uh i as i've changed a lot of positions
based on facts i changed my position on
that based on facts and i feel terrible
that i had that earlier position and
i've been super clear about it yeah the
the fact that you change it that's
respect to you for doing that you know
it was one and a half million armenians
give or take two to three hundred
thousand assyrians i want to say five
hundred thousand greeks when you you
read about the genocide it's a lot of
armenians but there's also syrians and
greeks part of that as well but might
might response back to your first
question would be not my first question
would be i don't think redskins need to
change their name just like you don't
need to change your name if your name is
young turks and you offend a guy like me
who's armenian and assyrian and i don't
like it i don't have to like it but i
don't have to say let's make sure he
changes his name it's your name and by
the way there is an armenian community
that's you know you look at the american
indian community what is the size of
that what is the armenian size community
what is the assyrian community what is a
greek community some people might say
dude that's offensive i get what you're
saying as a young progressive but it's a
young turks so i think
the the part where sometimes you know we
play this change your name i'm offended
i'm this i'm that i am offended but i
don't expect you to change it i expect
you to stay with the name that you
created that's the whole thing i'm
thinking about with the redskins thing
anyways that was one thing i friend of
mine brought it up i said let me talk to
jenk about it and see what it is i got
to tell you bro sincere i enjoyed having
you on like literally i really enjoyed
having you on and uh it's been it looks
like the audience uh
for the most part we have some people
that were pissed off but for the most
part the audience was very happy to have
you on and have this conversation gang i
don't know who we have next week can you
tell us who we have next week we got ken
golden monday ken golden monday kevin
farley tuesday kevin crosby
brothers tuesday dave rubin thursday
okay and uh
and joe jordan
friday joe jordan joe jorgensen
and possibly a another special guest on
so we don't want to say you know until
we we confirm it
one end but yeah we got a good week next
we got a busy week next week but this
was a fantastic week to finish the week
bro really really enjoyed you coming out
thank you for doing that so patrick adam
this is great i i love these
conversations because then you get the
full context and you find out what
people actually think and
anything i wanted to say to you i just
said it so i i love the open dialogue
loved it but gang i would suggest you
take this ex if this kind of topic is
intro obviously if you're
our audience you like this kind of stuff
i suggest you do sit down and watch this
with your peers i agree with jank here i
agree with pat here i disagree with both
of them here i agree with both of them
here this is how i get better i get
better by watching debates and today's
show hope was good for you guys
appreciate you guys for being with us we
appreciate you was the longest one ever
thank you for your loyalty thank you for
your time have a great weekend everybody
take care bye bye bye
you